Sure.
Three,
two,
one.
He.
Ha Ha.
Colin,
how are you buddy?
I'm good man.
How are you?
Good,
thanks.
What's going on?
What's cracking?
Not a lot.
It's a great honor for you to ask me
back.
I appreciate it.
Oh my pleasure,
dude.
I had a great time with you last time.
It's good to see,
but thank you.
Good to see you too.
Congratulations.
You were just showing me around this
space.
Thanks.
Very cool.
Thank you.
I'm very excited for weeks.
I'm excited too.
I bet.
Thanks man.
Appreciate it.
Jamie's moving shit around.
What happened?
Oh,
I was out of line.
Um,
so a welcome and a house Colin's last
stand going.
It's good.
It's fun.
It's,
you know,
I always describe it.
It's not big.
It's just got this little narrow slice
of the Internet and uh,
it's attracted,
you know,
videos do 20,
30,
40,
50,000
views and I have a good spot.
That's a good place to be.
I'm happy with it.
And uh,
you know,
I have like 4,500
people on Patriot and supporting me and
I don't serve ads on anything I do.
So I'm just trying to make it organic
and see how far I can take it and then
go from there.
Sam Harris says his entire podcast.
That way he doesn't have any ads,
which uh,
I think it's amazing.
Yeah,
it's cool.
Like I have no,
I,
you know,
I worked at ign for a long time,
the video game site and my old company
so we had ads and I have no problem with
them but I was trying to just kind of
say like,
I don't need more than what you're
giving me.
This is Brittany and I'm doing fine.
And so,
you know,
maybe I'll do ads on future products but
not with us dot well,
yeah,
I mean why not,
right.
I mean just if you're enjoying it.
I mean,
you.
Yeah.
Do,
you could do different products,
you could do different projects whether
you can do it different ways.
Yep.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's interesting now to try to figure
out like what's the best way for people
to put their stuff out there.
Like I know a lot of people,
like in the podcast world,
some people use soundcloud,
some puppies,
other things,
some people just go straight to youtube.
I mean it's a,
there's a lot of experimentation going
on now.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
I'm always fascinated by that particular
thing about how I do a podcast now just
on the side called fireside chats where
I just have random people into talk
about random things.
Um,
and uh,
it was similar but not nearly as good as
your show.
And uh,
I,
I'm always amazed that people are like,
why don't you put this on Youtube?
And I'm like,
you just want to stare at a static image
on youtube.
There's like,
not,
I don't even have it on video.
People just anxious about how people
consume the content.
So maybe like a spreadsheet approach is
probably the smartest idea.
Well,
if you could hire someone to do images
that represent the conversation,
maybe that would be a reason to have it
on youtube.
But I hear you.
Yeah.
It's people just get excited about our
platform.
They get locked into a platform and then
they just digest everything in that
platform,
whether it's snapchat or instagram or
youtube,
they just,
it's.
And it's weird with Jamie and I have
been talking about this a lot lately
about like what,
what makes it through,
like how did youtube become the only one
where people upload videos?
That seems insane.
It seems like that seems so
straightforward.
You have it so people can upload videos.
You put ads on those videos and that's
it.
I mean it seems like there would be
hundreds of those sites.
Yeah,
I think they were just first and it was
kind of like,
uh,
was like ubiquitous
quickly.
So I find that with a lot of like social
media too,
like you think about,
um,
like snapchat's really faltering now
because instagram is basically stolen
it's entire platform and it's all about
like kind of these little monopolies
that exist.
Monopolies were pictures,
monopolies for video,
monopoly for interacting with friends
and family on facebook and stuff like
that.
There's no thinking about,
there's no facebook competitor.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
facebook seems to me to be more
indulgent medium though it seems like,
like I've read some,
like sometimes I'll see people's
facebook posts and I just see the first
paragraph and then we'll see how long
ago was.
I'm like fuck,
reading that.
Just keep moving.
It's just too much.
It's so,
yeah,
it's like I find my girlfriend just
deactivated her facebook account and I
was like,
I don't find so much utility in it
anymore.
Especially after the election.
I'm like,
everyone hates each other on here and
it's not fun.
I already have twitter for that,
you know,
but like you're saying on twitter you
can't go on and on and on and on about
how much you hate Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton.
So there's like no way to retreat.
I find that I don't even use facebook
that much anymore.
I use it because my instagram posts
directly to twitter and to facebook.
That's how I use it.
And.
But it's interesting that it shows that
and the amount of people that engage
like my facebook as a fraction of what
everything else has and I think it's
because I don't use it.
Yeah,
I think.
I think algorithmically the more you use
it,
probably the more massages you to the
top of,
of a person's feet or whatever.
Because that's what's annoying about
facebook is you can't put anything in
order.
We have no idea what you've seen
already.
I was just talking to someone the other
day.
I only have 700 friends on there or
whatever.
A lot of people from college that I
might've had a class with or something
and I'm like,
why did the same 15 people to show up on
that?
I don't even interact with these people,
so I feel like I'm missing a ton of
stuff and I still find twitter is the
most useful for me.
People love facebook though for arguing.
They fucking love it,
man.
I,
I've gone over some political arguments
that people have on facebook and it's
like,
Jesus,
how do you have the time for this?
Do people have other things that you
enjoy?
Yeah,
know there's something about that sort
of tit for tat verbal exchange,
like trying to one up someone and trying
to make a better point and it's.
I feel like it's replaced sport for
people,
you know,
for some folks I feel like it's a game
and sort of what in some sort of a way,
like a text based video game or saying
yeah,
like an old text adventure or something
like that.
Yeah,
I,
I.
What I find in the.
One interesting thing about the
interesting thing about facebook that I
think is worth noting is that it's
typically real people with real names
and real picture,
so at least they're putting themselves
out there as opposed to twitter.
The kind of the anonymous nature of
that.
So I respect that for the most part on
facebook.
But again,
I agree with you,
it's like no one's winning this
argument.
It's just the repetitive.
How many times am I going to see the
same thing over and over again?
I've kind of just withdrawn from that
entirely because.
Yeah,
well you know,
I'm wanting to talk to you about
Internet controversy because when we had
you on the first time it was Kinda just
after your whole thing and happen with
this.
He had made this one like incredibly
innocuous tweet.
It was a like a day without women or
something like that.
Silence.
Like what was the tweet?
It was a our peace and quiet hashtag a
day without a woman.
Yeah,
I mean which is like an Al Bundy joke
maybe.
And but the thing is like if that
happened today,
nobody would give a shit.
It's weird.
It's like then it was,
it was a boiling controversial,
like the first bubbles of just social
media outrage.
It seems like you were one of the first
bubble.
All right.
Like I explained to you originally,
I feel like it was partially a political
hit because of the industry I worked in
and all of that kind of stuff.
But also like I was telling you before
we started the more.
I've had time to think after all things
things,
things happen.
I want you to a company.
I was working 70 hours a week.
I had no bandwidth to really think about
what the hell happened.
The more I think about it,
the angrier I actually got about about
like how I had to go through that and
watch other people also kind of go
through similar things as the outrage
machine just eats people and spits them
out as they go along.
When you stop it,
I think about what you actually said and
that,
that what that actually cost like that
actually caused you to stop working with
people like this one silly joke.
Like they don't know you.
They don't know.
You know that one joke that one thing
that you said is so awful and outrageous
that all of our years of collaborating,
working together,
trying to do projects,
trying to be creative,
having fun,
all the conversations we've had about
life and about humans and politics had
men and women.
Those are all out the window.
Man.
You made a joke that I find marginally.
Yeah,
maybe uncertain day.
Marginally offensive.
It's if it was a woman,
if a woman said that like a day of peace
and quiet a day without men.
Yeah,
that's what I would go out to keep them
and move on with your life.
The idea that like,
oh,
I've got to get this lady fired.
She's a terrible person.
It was the only thing that I can think
about is that I was at least in a
position where it didn't destroy me or
whatever.
Like I was.
I actually am doing,
you know,
financially better and feel happier and
what I'm doing now.
So it didn't,
it kind of backfired or other people
that we're trying to do whatever they
were doing to me anyway,
but I feel for the people that find
themselves in similar situations that
don't have and I don't know,
like some,
some sort of Internet cloud or some sort
of community that can kind of rally
around them and lift them up,
which is what my community did to me,
which I'm so appreciative of.
So I just think about how it's just sad.
Like I,
I don't know that I've ever been so
offended by something.
Somebody tweeted or even said that I
like went out of my way to,
to make it personal and try to destroy
them.
I'm not saying people don't do terrible
shit happens all the time where we're
seeing that play out with Harvey
Weinstein and all these kinds of things.
Absolutely awful really awful things and
I feel like people are kind of like
being distracted by the shiny object in
the corner when they're losing sight of
what's important.
Well today it feels like there's blood
in the water,
you know?
I mean,
it just,
it seems like there's so many people
going after so many people.
It's just people are running around
looking for targets.
I the way I met,
imagine I'm imagining like the Internet
and people on the Internet being like an
angry mob
running through the streets,
frothing at the mouth,
just looking for somewhere to point
their gun.
I mean,
that's really what it feels like.
It feels like there's definitely some
real targets out there.
Yeah,
there's definitely some.
This Kevin Spacey thing is,
is a scary thing.
I mean apparently Rosie O'donnell start
tweeting that he had been doing this
forever and that this is just the tip of
the iceberg and there's a bunch of boys
that he went after.
I don't know what's true,
what's not true right now.
I'm a,
I'm assuming,
but that's real.
That's a real horrible thing.
That's not a joke.
It's not someone with an innocuous maybe
off color joke.
I mean this is like real stuff.
So I think the good part is all of this
awful behavior,
predatory evil,
you know,
all the Harvey Weinstein and whatever
else is probably a million other ones.
Right.
That stuff's going to get exposed,
but it seems like the negative part
about it is that people are looking for
targets.
They're just,
you know.
Yeah.
And well that's what kind of scares me.
I was telling you,
I don't know if you're a black mirror
fan,
but I was,
well I've only watched one episode,
but I love it.
I highly recommend you get two eps.
I love that show and it's,
it's what's going on now.
Reminds me a little bit of like a Black
Mirror episode where like,
it's like people are,
like you said,
are targeting others,
but I feel and I feel like accusations
are part of the process are part of due
process really starts with the
accusation and I feel like people
aren't,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm not defending anything that anyone's
done,
but I feel like everyone just assumes
guilt no matter what and it scares me
because now we're getting to the point
where anyone can accuse someone of
anything at all and they're
automatically guilty and they're
automatically shame that I'm like,
but aren't you curious what's true?
Maybe half or 75 percent of this is
true,
but certainly not all of this is true.
Certainly not all of these accusations
are true at.
The one thing that I was interested in
is um,
Mark Halperin who the political writer
who was accused of things last week.
He didn't hear this one.
There's so many to keep up with.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's happening a lot.
Mark Halperin is a famous political
writer.
He wrote a game change and double down
those famous books.
About 2008 and 2012 with John Heilemann
who was his partner.
He was on Msnbc and all this stuff and
he was accused of some sexual harassment
when he was at ABC News in the early two
thousands.
And he came out and was basically like,
I'm sorry for my behavior and all that
kind of stuff.
And what I thought was interesting about
it was that he was like,
not all of these accusations are true,
but he kind of just then went on and
apologize and did all this and I'm like,
but I'm interested in,
in like,
what are you going to contest any of
this?
Like what is true and what isn't true?
Why aren't we interested in what is true
and what isn't true?
Clearly you are a scumbag in some way,
but I'm also curious in,
are you going to defend yourself?
Are we in a situation where no one can
defend themselves from these,
from these terrible accusations?
And it reminds me of a black mirror a
lot and that's a worthy accusations.
He was a basically accused of um,
heavily hitting on women like that were
junior than him.
Some when we're working with.
Yeah,
exactly.
Somewhere,
somewhere like,
I don't think any of them accused him of
sexual assault or anything like that,
but apparently he might've rubbed up
against some women or did some,
some things that are sexual assault.
Yeah,
presume I assume so,
but I guess what I'm saying is like on
somebody that's essentially sexual
assault,
I mean more like I don't think they're
accusing him of raping them or
something,
like something like something was
absolutely horrifying.
Horrific,
you know.
Um,
and I'm like,
well,
clearly,
you know,
I liked him a lot and I'm like,
well I can't,
I don't,
you know,
you're clearly not a good person.
But I was also just interested in that,
in that,
that dynamic of his statement where I
was like,
well,
what isn't true?
I'm curious what isn't true,
why,
you know,
it almost suggests that everything is
true,
but then you just never know any
situation.
So I just kind of reserve judgment until
more information is known about all of
these people.
And I'm not,
I don't want to jump in on it because I
don't know,
even want to know,
I mean,
unless it's people that are in my world,
I mean at a certain point in time,
look,
I mean I want to know about Kevin Spacey
type situations or Harvey Weinstein type
situations,
but I think there's a lot of men that
are in that position where they're are a
boss or they are,
you know,
the owner of a company and they have
these people under them and these people
behave in a certain way.
Like almost like as if they are royalty,
you know.
And I think that's what Harvey Weinstein
experienced.
I mean essentially he was like the
royalty of is this enormous movie
empire.
Right?
And we find that particularly offensive,
this not just,
he's not just a creep trying to get
laid.
He's a guy that was trying to hold that
power over people and use it against
them.
And then on top of that he was like
physically forceful.
So you've got like your worst case
scenarios and then you have guys that
are just trying to get laid and you're
like,
okay,
how do you,
what,
what we,
we demonizing aggressive
heterosexuality,
like where does this go?
Where does this go into sexual assault?
Like rubbing up against someone
physically touching them when they don't
want you to.
Well that's sexual assault but hitting
on someone but that doesn't seem like
sexual assault or anything.
It seems like someone just trying to get
laid,
like where does it?
But then when someone's the boss he
goes,
okay,
but then you're not supposed to do that
when you're a boss.
I always knew I was very interested in
the,
in the,
in the dynamic between what specifically
with Harvey Weinstein and his people
under him for many decades about.
I always trying to put myself in this
position of like,
how does this stay quiet for so long?
Even though there's a little rumblings,
like they talk about Seth Mcfarlane's
joke at some award show Kevin Spacey to
Family Guy,
family guy.
Like a little kid was running away from
silos with locked and Kevin Spacey,
spacement.
It's amazing that this stuff is kind of
like an open secret and so,
but still doesn't seep out or really.
And um,
it makes you think about the pie,
the power dynamics and how fearful
people are in these positions because
it's easy.
My initial instinct was like,
why didn't anyone say anything that was
similar to the bill cosby thing?
I'm like,
why didn't anyone say anything?
But then you realized people were saying
things.
They were,
they were being given hush money.
They were being shut up.
But these are really,
really bad people.
But I agree with you that it,
you know,
never been a um,
an aggressive flirt flirter as it were.
I've always been very passive with women
because I never really believed in
myself that much and all that.
But I've known people that have been
very flirtatious and,
and you know,
um,
and all of that,
I'm like,
I wonder what is the line there now?
And is it okay to,
to be flirtatious,
to call a woman beautiful at a bar or to
do something like that as opposed to,
you know,
kind of if a girl likes you,
that's the thing.
Like if you meet a girl at a bar and the
girl's like,
Colin is a really cool guy,
God,
I'm so into him and collins like,
you're really beautiful.
And she's like,
oh,
I gotta thank you.
And then next thing you know,
you guys are hanging out or you meet a
girl at a bar,
she has nothing.
She doesn't want to have anything to do
with you.
She's sober,
you're drinking,
your breath smells and you know,
like,
you're really beautiful and you're like,
oh gross,
get the fuck away from me.
You know,
it can be exactly the same attempt,
but the person is just not into you.
You become a creep.
Right?
Exactly.
So,
uh,
I,
I don't,
uh,
I don't look at the situation now in
2017 with on college campuses and all
these things as,
as desirable for anyone because who
knows who the hell knows the rules of
the landscape.
Now I think a lot of it just comes down
to mutual respect and all of that,
you know?
Well,
you know what I think it is,
man.
I really think we're shifting a like
culturally,
I think this is a big gigantic shift,
almost like an earthquake of
consciousness.
I think that over the course of human
history we have slowly but surely become
better to each other and like we were
playing.
We had a photograph that we put up
yesterday have an ad from 1911.
It was a gum add and it was a mixture of
instructing a man how to go about
kissing a woman and a lot of it was
like,
do not ask permission,
look in her eyes a gaze dreamily.
It was like really like weird to
instructing how to grab her face,
how to like,
leaned down to kiss her.
It was very,
very bizarre.
I was like,
if you tried to put that ad out today,
he will be fucking skewered publicly.
Yeah.
So after you.
But there's the ad right there.
Do you know how to kiss a girl?
Then learn,
stand facing her to not tell her your
intentions,
do not ask for permission to kiss her
urine and shit.
We went up whenever,
the whole thing yesterday so I won't go
over it again.
But that's funny.
It's the with the name of the game
again,
common sense.
What is it?
Common Sense Gum company,
the common sense gum company from 1911
and I think what's happening right now
is this a like a really big shift and I
think the beneficiaries of this big
shift are going to be the next
generation of kids that are growing up.
They're probably not going to have to
deal with nearly as much shit.
I think,
and I'm absolutely not giving bill cosby
any sort of fucking excuse at all,
but I think that in bill cosby's Day,
I think a lot of men did that.
I think it was really common.
I mean I don't think they thought
anything of it just like
you ever watch like an old clint
eastwood movie and they slap women.
They just used to beat the shit out of
women in those movies.
Times have changed it and they're
changing now like today at an
unprecedented rate.
I think ultimately it's good.
Um,
I ultimately everyone,
when you,
you catch people at like a,
a good static state,
like a good calm state and you,
if they're not under duress and they're
thinking clearly and to ask them like,
what,
what's the best way to get along with
other people?
What's about,
won't treat them fairly.
Treat them kindly,
have good friends.
Just be nice,
be nice to everybody.
Everybody would agree with that.
But the problem is maybe they want
something from you,
like column wants to fuck the girl at
the bar,
but she's sober and collins got gross
breath and he's,
you know,
like,
you know what I mean?
There's just all sorts of extenuating
circumstances that make people behave.
I'm really fucked up ways.
But the consequences of those
circumstances or that,
that behavior was,
was minimized by power.
Right?
It was minimized by,
you know,
like a guy like Harvey Weinstein.
They could put these gals on movies,
you know,
or a guy like Kevin Spacey was hitting
on a 14 year old and has no one to say,
you know,
all that stuff that,
that,
that ability to squash it,
it minimized people,
you know,
it reminds me to,
not that I know deeply anything deep
about it,
but I was just thinking about it in the
shower this morning actually.
It reminds me a lot of Michael Jackson
and the sense of like,
what,
what was going on in the early mid
nineties with him in the accusations
there.
And I'm like,
was this,
I don't know if that's true or false.
I don't know what he's accused
overnight.
People kind of,
I think treat him as if he was innocent.
Maybe he is,
I don't know.
But it reminds me of like,
there was like telltale signs of some of
some sexual corruption and Hollywood and
the music industry,
the movie industry in all of that and
some years ago,
um,
that's kind of bubbled back to the
surface with some big names.
So I just,
I agree with you like it.
I just wish people just need to be good
to talk to each other and like act
normal and these guys and and be
respectful and these things.
You don't find yourself in these
terrible situations,
but then you see this desperation with
Harvey Weinstein where you,
you learned that he might've sexually
assaulted,
even raped the woman who then appears in
a movie some years later because he,
he,
the gravity well around him is so strong
that they have no choice.
So it's a very sad situation for those
women as well.
Situation for humanity.
Right.
It's like there's just certain things
that people were able to get away with.
You know,
like the cosby thing to me is probably
number one.
That's the number one worst whenever,
because he represented this sort of like
really moral,
very ethical,
you know,
like doesn't,
doesn't swear on stage.
Like he's the last one that you would
expect to be what he's described been
described as the number one serial
rapist of all time and you're like,
wait,
wow.
Is that,
how is that possible?
It's
incredible.
It's just a crazy on an unfortunate and
sad situation and ruined his whole
legacy,
you know?
Um,
you know,
like who,
who could ever.
I seen the cosby show,
I don't
even know if it's syndicated anymore
since all the accusations came up,
but who could watch that now and,
and,
and just look past that.
Like I certainly don't,
especially because a lot of that is
contemporaneous to that show is still on
the air.
Well,
I don't,
I,
I assume that they got their stuff
pulled.
There's something capable.
What about Fat Albert?
That'd be weird.
Yeah.
Again,
again,
contemporaneous to a lot of his
accusations going back to,
to um,
uh,
what was that original show that he did
in the high spot?
Right?
Yeah.
That was the first one,
right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's like,
I think a lot of that's like 50 years
where the accusations like,
Holy Shit,
you know,
Hollywood was a different animal back
then is a different animal when people
didn't have a voice,
you know,
but do you,
because you have some,
you have,
you,
you're,
you were on TV and you do it.
You do hear rumblings like this,
I mean,
I'm not asking you to be specific,
but do you hear.
Well I haven't been on TV in a long
time,
but I did hear the cosby thing way back
in the nineties.
I heard that when I was on the set of
news radio,
I remember people talking about it,
but,
and I had heard the Kevin Spacey thing
too,
but you know,
you don't,
you don't know.
You know,
it's not like,
well you should have gone to the press,
like with what information,
you know,
like someone accused Rosie O'donnell
because Rosie O'donnell was talking
about Kevin Spacey.
She's like,
you're a Sicko.
You know,
everyone knew you were a Sicko.
And so someone said,
hold on a second.
So you're saying that you knew that he
was like this and you didn't do anything
about it?
And she.
And she said,
well there was always rumors,
but no one had any evidence right now
until this actor came forth.
Is he an actor or a director and is a
broadway actor.
Which Broadway.
Yeah,
that's the whole thing is fucked.
He was in television show though.
He was a Broadway actor with Kevin
Spacey in Nineteen.
Whatever the hell it was when,
when this happened 30 years ago.
What do you think about the whole
misdirection thing in his statement too?
About being like crazy weird.
Sneaky.
Yeah.
Not Good.
I think very,
very transparent,
very transparent.
Deflecting.
Now I live my life as a gay man.
Hey,
fuck face.
Nobody asked you.
Did you try to rape a kid?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
It was very weird.
I don't know why he decided to do that.
Well,
I think he's probably panicking,
you know,
I mean and ultimately he probably should
be.
Yeah,
I,
I would assume so.
Especially because maybe there are more
accusations and then the whole weird
thing with Netflix with house of cards
where they were like,
this is going to be the last season now.
Apparently they stopped production so
they stopped the completely.
So Jamie was saying,
oh,
interesting.
This morning I'll shut up,
pull it up.
Okay.
Yeah,
because I thought that was interesting
specifically because they had apparently
heard already announced that it was the
last season anyway.
Like in the summer,
so they're making it seem like they're
reacting to it.
So everyone's just playing the PR game
now,
you know,
I wonder.
Yeah.
I don't know because they made an
announcement pretty quickly.
Maybe they made it an announcement
sorta.
Just to let everybody know,
you know?
Yeah.
That is the last season,
but okay.
Here it goes.
Production on Netflix,
special series suspended indefinitely
following Kevin Spacey.
Allegations.
Is it allegation or s?
S is this poor girl?
Yeah,
there.
Is there a second or third allegation
that I might've missed it?
I'm sure he has a Gore vidal movie that
they're filming as well,
which will be interesting.
It's an interesting guy.
Corporate.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Did you know what's a great fucking
film?
I'm Gore Vidal.
And um,
who's the super conservative guy?
William F Buckley at a series of debates
in 1960,
I want to say 68.
And they televise them and it,
it was like a huge boom to whatever
network it was.
ABC,
I believe it was.
And um,
they made a documentary about these two
going back and forth with each other.
It's brilliant.
It's amazing and it's so interesting to
see their minds.
I'm interacting with each other.
Wasn't that the debate series where
William f Buckley said something super
homophobic?
Yeah.
Called him,
called him.
She called him a Faggot,
like yeah.
Unlike network television,
and he said he would.
He would knock him out.
He'd said something like,
you'll stay plastered or something like
that.
I forget his,
his,
his statement,
but Gore Vidal said something to William
f Buckley that like really pushed his
button on her.
I don't remember what he said to him
because I remember watching and being
like,
oh my God was dead,
but it was devastating to William f
Buckley.
It was pretty much the end of his being
taken seriously because people realized,
well,
he's kind of a fool and his ego and his
mind is just not within his control and
it just got out of hand and Gore Vidal
just sort of sat there while you said
it,
right?
Yeah.
Corbin Allison.
Interesting.
My exposure to him,
and initially it was like he wrote,
I think some historical fiction about
some various things that now listen,
you queer,
stop calling me a Crypton Nazi or I'll
socking your goddamn face and you'll
stay plastered.
Whoa.
That's like incredible to listen to you
queer.
Stop calling me a crypto Nazi.
Whoa.
I'm concerned.
The only pro or crypto Nazi I can think
of is yourself.
So people were calling each other Nazis
even way back after,
you know,
right after World War Two.
Yeah.
It's a weird one,
right?
It's like,
the problem is like when we,
what we saw in Charlottesville is like,
hey look guys,
there's real Nazis.
Like don't call someone a Nazi because
they voted for trump because they think
that uh,
you know,
a right wing,
conservative values are being diminished
in this country.
Don't call him a Nazi for that.
It just bothers me.
The same thing with the word fascist
where I'm like,
you don't even really understand what
these words mean.
A lot of you like,
I don't.
These words aren't only loaded.
They have definitions and I don't know
what it's like when everyone says we
live in a fascist state in America
today,
and I'm like,
I don't think so.
The courts seem to be working fine.
The congress doesn't do anything but
it's there.
I lived in a fascist state.
Then there wouldn't be an investigation
against trump.
Right,
exactly.
I'm leading to indictment.
Exactly in which he actually has the
power to fire the person doing the
investigation.
So it's,
it's,
you know,
I'm not saying we're in an ideal
situation right now,
but people throwing around these words
very loosely need to learn a little bit
more about why more Republican that
Nazis coming
to power and 33 and what that actually
looks like,
what fascism actually looks like in
Italy,
what it looks like in Germany and they
have no idea or a lot of some people do
but most don't.
And they're.
And they're just throwing these words
around and they mean something.
Well,
there's a lot of it
confusion today in terms of like why
free speech is important and one of the
reasons why free speech is important is
because you don't get to decide what is
correct.
It has to be debated,
you know?
Um,
there was a,
I forget who,
it's,
who,
who said that?
It was really recent.
We talked about it yesterday.
Oh,
it was that guy that the Yale professor
that was on Sam Harris show hit a
perfect statement about the guy who got
in trouble for his wife with the,
the Greek fellow.
His wife had defended offensive
Halloween costumes and the kids went
crazy and arrested him.
Right public.
He said the answer to,
to hate speech is not no speech,
it's better speech.
And that's such a great statement.
That's absolutely true.
It's absolutely true.
So like all these kids that are trying
to shut down conservative speakers on
campus and then by shutting down they're
calling them white supremacist Nazis and
using these things for guys like Ben
Shapiro,
which I think is patently ridiculous.
The,
the,
the Jewish,
the Jewish Nazi,
and a white supremacist as well,
which is just like,
because he quotes statistics about
minority crime,
you know,
those statistics I feel like are pretty
misleading in some ways because there's
a lot of factors that lead to these
people being in these situations where
there's high crime rates and these
communities and it has nothing to do
with,
you know,
hey,
you need to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps,
which is like a really common way of
looking at it,
right on us to do with the world that
they were born into.
Socioeconomically.
It's a different,
different world.
Yeah.
And they're surrounded by the momentum
of crime.
They're surrounded by the momentum of
violence and abuse and to just expect
them to escape that because there are
examples of people that have done it in
the past.
You can't apply that,
that sort of logic.
I don't think,
uh,
I think that's disingenuous.
But to call him a Nazi or a white
supremacists,
I think it was fucking ridiculous.
Well,
that's just such,
it's just such a,
it's just used pejoratively without
historical context.
I,
it's,
it's exactly what it is because it
reminds me a little bit,
it's different in the context,
but it reminds me a little bit of when
Bernie Sanders was running in the
primary and people will be like,
this is,
look at what socialism has given you,
look at the roads and,
and unlike the roads are not,
roads aren't socialists,
the military is not socialist,
streetlights aren't socialists.
The government spending money is not
what socialism means.
So that's what you think the definition
means.
Then you're wrong.
And the same thing with now Nazis and
fascism,
like look at all the parallels between
Nazi Germany and the United States.
And I'm like,
I couldn't.
I'm a student of history.
I'm not,
I don't know everything,
but I don't see literally one parallel
between the United States right now and
Nazi Germany.
Not even one.
So we're not coming off a war
last.
We're not,
you know,
a devastated and humiliated.
Yeah,
the stabbing them back.
Hyperinflation.
Uh,
this charismatic who's in prison for
awhile
writes this manifesto,
tries to actually throw a coup in the
mid twenties,
fails all,
like all these,
like,
oh,
I'll make what are the,
what parallel are you talking about
that,
you know?
And so I just feel like people are
playing fast and loose with these words
that they mean something.
They,
these words mean something.
So we're going to call someone a
fascist,
find the fascias and like you said,
there are Nazis in an American culture
unfortunately,
but fortunately because of our freedom
of expression,
they have the right to exist.
And I think that by lumping in anyone
that voted for trump for instance,
as a Nazi,
you're just making them look bigger.
That actually just benefits them there.
There are irrelevant.
The KKK is a relevant 6,000
members maybe in a,
in a country of 300,
$25 million people.
How many people identify as Neo Nazi?
Really?
Maybe $10,000
or less,
you know,
but what are you thinking about?
Three hundred 50 million people.
It's a very small number.
It's infant infant infancy.
It's actually irrelevant,
completely irrelevant.
But if you're a black guy and they're
all coming after you on your facebook
page,
then it looks good.
It looks real.
And,
and,
and it is that kind of badgering and
that kind of harassment is real and it's
terrible.
No,
no one justifies that.
But I am so sick of the history,
like the,
the,
like people have suddenly are our
experts.
It reminds me of on Columbus Day I
tweeted out and it got tweeted a bunch.
I though it was funny where people are
tweeting about Columbus and all of a
sudden sudden suddenly everyone's an
expert now in the age of exploration
today.
Now everyone knows everything about the
age of exploration,
just like everyone knew everything about
the rise of Nazi-ism and the Weimer
Republic.
And just like everyone knew about the,
you know,
socialism and all.
I'm like,
stop,
you know,
I posted this flag behind me,
uh,
and a company called iron mountain
designs creates it.
And so veteran owned company and they
make these pretty cool flags,
man.
Very cool.
Flags made out of metal.
But it has a George Washington quote on
the back.
And I put it up on instagram with the
photo of the flag photo,
the logo of the company,
like three different pictures on
instagram in a row,
you know,
you do that.
We're one post can have three images and
one of them was a quote from George
Washington and the number of fucking
geniuses,
George Washington owned slaves.
Would you use an honest man on swerves?
And they just kept rattling on about the
horrors of George Washington as if.
Okay.
Yep,
he did.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
But this is a quote by a man who lived
hundreds and hundreds of years ago,
and this is what he said,
you know,
you want to diminish his entire
contribution to human culture because he
did something horrible back then when
people were doing horrible things.
You're,
you're right.
He did own slaves.
But I think it's a part of a very long
conversation about what a human being
was.
You know,
back then.
Yeah.
It goes back to the idea of historical
relativism that like you can't,
you can judge them based on the 21st
century model.
But George Washington died in 1799.
So this is a man that didn't even see
the 19th century.
Nonetheless.
The 20th nonetheless.
The 21st has no idea what that was.
He was a southern plant there for the
first five presidents of the United
States where southern plant,
there's that owned slaves.
It's not a totally uncommon thing.
So I'm not justifying it there would
absolutely among
the founders,
they were absolutely abolitionists
during the revolution and and black
people fought for the,
for the continental army.
But yeah,
people judging based on these things,
I'm like that's fine,
but if you want to take that to the to
its natural conclusion,
you're going to find lots of problems
with lots of people even closer to us in
history than than George Washington.
And what's funny about that is now there
really are going.
After I was reading it just
tangentially,
I didn't see at all,
but people are starting to now go after
George Washington plaques or George
Washington statues and I feel kinda bad
about that in the sense that I was all
for removing the confederate statues and
putting them in places where they made
sense.
So take the,
the Jefferson Davis statue,
put it in Gettysburg or whatever the
case might be,
put in a museum.
I don't think they should be melted down
and destroyed,
but people were like,
the next logical step is they're going
to go after the founders and I was like,
no way will any like no one's going to
let that happen and I was wrong.
You know,
now they are going after him
immediately.
So I feel a little bit guilty about that
in a sense that,
you know,
I don't think we should be celebrating
confederate history,
but we should absolutely be celebrating
American history.
Even even the complicated American.
It's not celebrating it,
it's recognizing it and understanding
it.
I mean the confederate war,
the civil war rather did happen.
It's,
it's a real historical fact and it
should be studied and if you don't study
it,
you don't get a comprehensive
understanding of all the pieces that
were in place when it did happen.
And you know,
it's just as bad as the people that are
saying,
you know,
civil war was about economics and.
No,
no,
it wasn't.
It was part of what it was about.
It wasn't just about economics,
it was also about keeping slaves.
That's a fact.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So like to diminish that,
it does,
like,
that's not good either,
but to,
to try to sweep it under the rug and
smash all the statutes,
like know,
have that statue up so people can
understand what the fuck that is.
And if someone is going to celebrate
that statue,
you know,
south go and do it again,
we're going to rise again.
They can do that,
you know,
if that's,
if that's their thing,
they can do that.
I mean we can't stop them from thinking
stupid.
Yeah.
And I think that I agree with you in the
sense that it's,
it's worth it just,
it,
it happened or we remember it and it has
always the grandma,
the Grandpa who have always been part of
our culture since,
since the civil war ended in 18,
65,
and especially since the reconstruction
ended in 18,
77.
We've had,
don't even know what you're saying.
The gray and blue uniforms of the,
of the different sides.
Um,
you know,
when reconstruction ended in 18,
77 in our occupation of the south ended
and then Jim crow came,
became law and there was no
institutional segregation.
This was something that was always a
complicated point of celebration.
You know,
I've always been,
I've always been really kind of curious
and really more militant about why these
people actually got away with what they
did.
And I understand,
um,
you know,
the 10 percent plan,
which we,
do you know,
anything about that,
that the idea that Lincoln only made are
actually really,
Andrew Johnson only made 10 percent of
people in the southern states.
Basically a pledge allegiance in order
to,
for the states to come back in.
They didn't execute.
Anyone that you know or even really try
them.
You know,
Jefferson Davis,
a stonewall Jackson didn't survive,
but Robert e Dot Lee and all these other
guys just got away with it and actually
lived pretty prosperous lives
afterwards.
So there's always been this really
complicated mix of,
of remembrance that these people down
there were heroes and we don't have to
support that.
I certainly don't support that,
but it goes way further back than our
contemporary culture and we can't just
smash it into oblivion and think that
you're going to remove that.
The heritage of the stars and bars and
all of that from,
from what happened.
I think that the problem is people think
that you're celebrating the confederate
army when you have a statue up and in
some ways you kind of.
It seems like you are right because the
statutes 15 feet tall and he's got a
sword in his hand and he's on a horse
and he's marching forward and you know,
people look at it as if it's celebrating
something that's a horrible part of
human culture.
It is.
I mean,
I remember going to Richmond,
Virginia for the first time.
I,
my fam.
A lot of my family lives down there now
and they have this thing called monument
row or whatever where it's just a.
it's like Jefferson Davis and Robert e
Dot Lee,
and then they actually put Arthur ash at
the end to make it seem like it's not
racist anymore.
Which I always thought was weird.
They did that in like the seventies or
eighties.
Yeah,
exactly.
So there's just like a black guy at the
end of it's like we were,
this isn't racist at all.
Um,
and it's a bonus that he died of aids.
So everyone,
so everyone.
Yeah.
So we have a lot of diversity,
HIV,
HIV culture and all that.
But um,
you know,
I remember being really confused when I
was a kid being like,
why are these statutes here?
This doesn't make any sense.
And I agree that they shouldn't be in
those places of reverence because
they're beyond the slavery issue.
And I agree with you.
Slavery was the reason the confederacy
was founded.
It does go back to state's rights and it
has inherent economic benefits,
but it is,
you know,
Stephen Douglas,
who was the vice president of the
confederacy,
literally said that they were founded
because of this,
so you can take his word for it,
but I was always confused why we were
celebrating,
um,
these people and why not?
Why not have these pieces of art because
they are pieces of art,
but have them in places that make sense.
That give context,
um,
so I have no problem with that,
but I,
I,
I was so tragically wrong about the
slippery slope that we were finding
ourselves on because I thought people
would see more of that.
Like,
yes,
Thomas Jefferson was a complicated man
but also immensely important person to
our,
you know,
our society,
but people aren't seeing it that way and
I will,
I will fight more vociferously to
protect those guys.
Then I did the confederate confederate
officers for sure.
Even though those guys did own slaves
too,
right?
I mean,
it is all weird when you're talking
about slave ownership.
You know,
I did this thing this morning,
my kids school,
they have this great pumpkin day and all
the kids are onstage and they're,
they have this little plate.
They act out in one of the things that
we're talking about,
the smell of Apple Bacon and mmm.
And everybody's like,
oh,
the smell of applewood bacon.
And all I could think of,
because yesterday we were talking about
factory farming and about Glenn
Greenwald article where I'm this FBI
investigation to these two people that
stole these pigs from this factory farm
revealed this federal coverup of these
horrific conditions in factory farms.
And I was thinking of like one day we're
going to look at like factory farming
and the horrific nature of what they do
to these animals,
especially pigs.
These really intelligent animals stuffed
into these boxes and make them live in
their own shit.
And there's little corpses of piglets
around them really for the article.
And the photos were really hard to look
at.
And I was thinking while I was watching
this little little kids play today,
I was like,
one day we're going to look back at this
mention of Bacon and we're going to
think like how fucked up where people
that they thought it was okay to shove
these little animals into these crates
and make them live in their own shit
just so you can get bacon off.
But we've just sort of accepted that
it's a part of our culture and that it's
not a valid comparison to slavery,
but it's also,
it's not an ideal way for a conscious
and evolving species like the human race
to behave.
It's not a good way for us to
rationalize.
And I was looking at that today and I
was thinking,
how many more of these things mean?
I think we're seeing that with things
like the Harvey Weinstein allegations
and this outrageous coming forth.
I think we're seeing a lot of the
aspects of our society that's getting
exposed in a way that it never got
exposed before.
But I think we're also seeing it in my
mind,
we were seeing it with this talk of
Bacon.
I was like,
you know,
look,
Bacon is delicious.
Absolutely.
But where the fuck's that bacon coming
from,
you know,
how you making sure you're getting free
range bacon from,
you know,
very,
uh,
moral and ethical farming practice.
This is,
are you just getting bacon?
Yeah.
It's actually a very thought provoking
what you're saying,
because I've always found the factory
farming.
I'm not that I'm an expert in that at
all.
I'm not,
but the argument to be really
interesting because it's like there's an
opportunity cost.
The way we treat these animals means
food is very cheap,
way cheaper.
Meat is incredibly cheap in the United
States compared to almost anywhere else
in the world.
Um,
and produces too because of that,
people use to spend a third of their
income before World War Two on food and
now they spend less than a 10th of their
money on food.
So there's some amazing.
So there's an interesting.
So we've made food way cheaper,
but you're right,
because you could make the same argument
for slavery in the sense that like,
well look at all the economic benefits
of it,
you know,
it kind of turned a blind eye to it.
So you actually kind of like not just
kind of changed my mind on a little bit
because I've always been of the mind
where like free range eggs,
free range animals.
That's great if you can afford that,
but I don't begrudge the poor or middle
class or working class family from going
and buying their ground beef from vons.
Yeah,
well if you're poor,
you got to get by right now.
There's that right.
And you're
system that you didn't design,
you didn't create.
You're just,
you're in there and you're just trying
to get by.
I understand that,
but what I'm just saying that like as a
whole,
as a culture to just openly accept
factory farming and to not think of it
as a horrific ethical and moral
injustice.
I mean it really is.
You know,
mrs coming from someone who eats meat,
right?
So obviously you could see the Vegan
argument would be,
well you're complicit in it and you are
also complicit in a bunch of other
horrific crimes against animals.
I think that what we're looking at
though is an under,
on wakening and sort of an understanding
of our impact,
like physically our impact on this end,
but mentally the way we think about
things,
the way we even think about ourselves.
If you know that your bacon is coming
from an animal that was tortured and
shoved into a cage and you buy it
anyway,
like,
whew.
You know,
how,
what does that do to your mind?
Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's,
it's sort of a,
it's a conundrum.
You know,
like what you,
you obviously hunting stuff like that.
But when you buy meat,
do you go out of your way to make sure
that it's a by almost.
No.
Me.
So you.
So you all that you eat is typically so
now it's taken a few years to do it,
but now,
I mean I shot to elk this year.
An elk is,
you know,
they're close to a thousand pounds so
you're just seeing so many of hundreds
of pounds of meat and I have to
commercial freezers here.
I have to have my garage at home.
I give it out to my friends.
I eat elk four nights a week,
you know,
and when I go out to dinner though,
I do eat steak,
you know,
if I go out to dinner at some
restaurant,
I don't ask where it came from right
now.
So in that way,
I'm a hypocrite.
Oh,
not necessarily.
I mean,
I think,
I think striving is important,
right?
You can't always be perfect but,
but being better,
I think if everyone was better as
opposed to being perfect than the
situation would be better.
So this,
the reality of there's an economic
reality.
Um,
I can take the time off,
I can take two weeks off out of the year
because I went to on to Elkanns,
um,
I've been on for hunt's this year in
three of them I was successful and one
of them I got an access deer which was
also like 100 pounds of meat.
And so that's most of what I eat,
but most people don't have time to take
three weeks off a year and then you also
have to have the time to practice and
you have to know people like a lot of
fortune,
good fortune on my side to be able to do
something like this.
But it's also a concerted effort and
becoming obsessed with the idea behind
it of doing that,
you know?
Yeah.
It becomes a different thing.
It who comes into like food is just a
different thing.
I mean,
if you grow tomatoes in your garden,
that food becomes a different thing.
It's like almost spiritual in a way.
You're like a connection to it.
It's an overused word,
spiritual kind of a word that's sort of
been hijacked.
Sure.
But yeah,
like,
yeah,
like there's a little,
there's a lot of words that have been
hijacked.
The word spirituality is really hijacked
by morons,
you know,
as someone says,
I'm really spiritual eyes.
I see.
Unfortunately,
tattoos and wouldn't beads and nutty
talk,
you know,
Reiki healers.
It was at the Golem Reiki,
I don't know.
Yeah.
You know,
those people that think they can heal
you by rubbing their hands above your
skin.
Is that Reiki?
Is that what they call it?
Yeah.
But yeah,
there's,
there's a,
um,
a completion of the cycle in,
in,
in lieu of a better word.
There's a,
like I grow food in my backyard and I
grow plants and vegetables.
I when I
eat them,
it just feels like some sort of a
completion,
like it feels good,
whereas it just feels like a good salad
if I get it at a store.
Right.
Well,
it's a year.
It's interesting.
You're almost subsistence living in a
way because you're hunting your own meat
and yeah,
you're growing some of your own produce.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah,
but I,
I wonder.
I'm just need the.
I need the grid for electricity.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Someone's gotTa build the bows and the
arrows.
I buy from a manufacturer the yet you're
very strict tolerances.
It's sort of subsistence,
but it's.
There's all these companies that are
involved behind creating the materials
that are used to.
So it's,
it's like capitalism is a slash sepsis a
subsistence,
but it's.
It's interesting because it's,
it's,
it's the point I made earlier.
You're further along in the path of
sustainability or further along the path
of some sort of righteousness and the
way animals are treated and all that
kind of stuff than a lot of people are.
So it's a step in the right direction.
Right.
I just wonder if people,
just to play devil's advocate again,
the working class family that at the
median household income of $40,000
a year,
if they,
if we got rid of some of these animal
practices which are important,
but if we got rid of them,
you know,
are they willing to pay 13 or $14 a
pound for their beef?
They probably couldn't afford it.
And that's a real problem.
I mean,
it's absolutely a real problem and I
think that,
um,
there's a lot of people that don't do,
they don't even take it into
consideration.
I mean,
that's,
that's probably the biggest problem that
we've,
we've made this system and everybody who
was born into this system,
you know,
obviously we didn't create it,
but we're,
we're born into a system and it took us
until we were probably like,
I didn't even know what a factory farm
was until I was 30.
I'd never even heard of it.
And then you hear about factory farming,
you go,
wait,
what does that.
I think all these animals,
they all stuffed together and you're
like,
what?
I thought the farms were like,
animals roamed around like I didn't,
I didn't know what.
I never even thought about it.
Yeah,
terrific.
I remember in the late nineties on TV,
like on public access or on like I
don't,
I think it was just on public access.
You would see these guerrilla filming
sessions that these guys would go to
these farms and like break in and take
all these pictures and it was like for
some animal rights activist group or
whatever.
And I,
I was always familiar with it.
I just never.
I mean I'm guilty of saying like,
I never really thought about it too
deeply beyond that sadly because I was
just.
I thought about the economic realities
of it where I'm like,
this is a terrible thing and we can fix
it.
Well,
we just have to have a conversation as a
society of what that's gonna mean for
food because the exact inverse has
happened with produce where we figured
out ways to really dramatically alter
seedlings.
And,
and you know,
I was just reading about Norman Borlaug
who won a Nobel peace prize for what he
did to wheat,
making wheat and we got,
sorry,
golden week I think.
I think that's what it is.
Yeah,
like where the protein and yeah,
and like a higher yield but the stock
wouldn't collapse and all that.
And he's apparently responsible for,
you know,
like there used to be these doomsday
prophecies in the sixties and seventies
people.
People forget that earth kind of golden
rice.
I'm talking,
I'm sorry.
Different things.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Uh,
there was this people look back at the
original Earth Day,
I think in 1970 when they often talk
about some of the,
the prognostications of what's happening
to the earth and all of that today.
But a lot of people will lost sight of
the fact that a lot of what people were
talking about then was that we were
going to die of famine.
That the earth,
Earth's population was growing way too
quickly and that they would have these
guesses by the late seventies,
early eighties and go read it.
It's fascinating.
They would be like,
by 1980 5 billion people are going to
die of starvation because we can't feed
everyone and all these kinds of things.
That's what they were originally talking
about.
So there's been these pioneering heroes
and agriculture that have figured it out
that have had these high yield crops and
all of that and we're fine with that
because obviously crops flora are
different than Fonda.
They don't,
you know,
they don't feel they don't have,
they don't have some sort of connection
with them.
They don't have a brain.
So I understand the differences or are
there,
but it's funny how these things have
totally basically switched sides where
now where you have these high yield
produce,
that's great.
We have these high yield ways of getting
animal meat but,
but no good.
And I,
I think that there are different things,
but does it suggest that we have to be
more Vegan or vegetarian?
All those kinds of things.
I don't.
I don't know if that's the answer.
I think we have to have a complicated
conversation and maybe it comes down to
this idea of cloning meeting or whatever
they're doing,
like making meat and you know,
process these weird chemical processes
to make beef that's indistinguishable
from real beef.
I mean,
that's fine if that.
If it tastes good,
I think that's probably what's going to
happen.
I think it's probably going to be like
these headless cows.
You could just grow in a lab,
just sliced chunks off of them or
something.
I mean,
I don't know how they're doing this meat
thing.
I don't really know either and I'm sure
it brings up a whole new slew of
bioethical questions too,
but that's just that.
Also probably health issues is probably.
I mean who's going to be the first
person to live 10 years off of that bio
meet before they figure out it causes
some inoperable colon cancer,
right?
Because your body doesn't know how to
process it correctly and it sticks to
the walls of your colon and starts
creating abscesses and they have to
remove your colon and make a new one
with stem cells.
Cut you open like a fish and who's going
to ditch this new shitter inside of you?
Who's going to get,
who's going to be the Guinea pig?
Someone will be as always,
I don't know.
And again,
not everybody can go hunt wild animals.
And if you did,
there would be no more wild animals.
I mean that's really what the great
market hunting of the um,
the early 19th century.
That's in the 18th century as well,
I think.
I think when they started that,
I think they started in the 17 hundreds,
started hunting buffalo and antelope.
And by the time the early 19 hundreds,
it was almost like completely wiped out.
We had almost no animals left because it
was from market hunting,
wasn't people hunting for their own
personal use is that they didn't have
refrigerators back then remember.
So you had to get meat and it didn't
last very long and they had to get a new
supply of it constantly and they would
just go out and they would take these
guys that were from the war and they
didn't have jobs.
And so this was their job.
Now they would go out and hunt antelope
and elk and deer and then sell that meat
at the market.
And what's interesting too about that is
that it's the human condition.
It's not only like the more modern human
condition,
I'm reading a book or I just read a book
called 1491,
which is about the condition of the,
of north and South America and Central
America before,
before Columbus.
So there was biking contact and stuff.
But,
um,
and they were talking about,
you know,
which is I think,
well known to a lot of people that,
that the native Americans,
the Paleo Indians wiped out tons of
animals before,
when there was literally only a few
hundred thousand of them,
you know,
because they were over hunting them.
So this,
this cycle continues know,
regardless,
and you even hear about that in Iceland
with a nurse that lived there,
were they like depleted there?
They're very precious woodstock there.
There's no animals.
A lot of it's not just modern humans
that are,
that are challenged by this.
A lot of,
you know,
the,
the woolly mammoth and all of these
animals were wiped out by humans,
you know.
So it's very
virtual by the way that,
that is.
Um,
there's a lot of people that believe
that that had to coincide because the
dates coincide with the end of the ice
age.
And there's a guy that I've had on this
podcast several times named Randall
Carlson and he has some very compelling
evidence that points to the possibility
that it was asteroidal impact that,
that wiped out these animals and mass.
And it's one of the reasons why in
certain parts of the world you could
find mass graveyards of animals that
were killed almost instantly.
And this was 10,000
years ago,
were saying interesting because I had
12,000
years ago.
They think there's two possible large
impacts that happened.
So they weren't bold lives.
They were,
they were actually,
they actually struck the.
So they weren't like the Tunguska event
with an explosion.
They actually hit.
They think it struck the ice sheet above
North America.
Oh,
interesting.
So there will be no evidence.
Well,
North America will though.
They think that that was the reason why
there's this,
it's a fascinating podcast to go back
and listen to.
And He,
um,
I had him on with another guy named
Michael Shermer was a famous skeptic and
Graham Hancock who was also a proponent
of some of his ideas and they showed all
these images of like these deep fissures
that were cut into the,
into the land that must have been a
massive amount of water over a very
short period of time.
And he thinks it was probably a large
body that slammed into the polarized
caps are slammed into rather the ice
caps that are above,
you know,
North America,
somewhere around 10,000
years ago at two miles high of ice,
over much of the surface of it and all
sudden boom,
gone.
And that's what caused the Great Lakes.
The Great Lakes are essentially these
gigantic glaciers that melted and
there's all sorts of features in these
various landscapes that he believes
point to massive amounts of water that
happened over an incredibly short period
of time and the explanation for that and
the peaks in the rises and the falls in
temperature during that time when they
do like a core samples of the earth,
he thinks that that also points to some
sort of an impact.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Randall Carlson studying this his whole
life,
he had an idea once when he was on acid.
He went and looked at this,
a gigantic canyon when he was on acid
and he had this idea that this all
happened because of water.
It was trying to piece it together and
then it became fascinating and started
studying it and then
got really into asteroidal impacts and
he's a wealth of knowledge but really,
really fast and you've got to talk to
you.
That's fascinating.
I love that stuff,
man.
That's what's so frustrating and why I
didn't study in college are really super
interested in ancient history or even,
you know,
Paleo history in prehuman history and
stuff because it's also hypothetical.
You'll never really know.
You know,
you have to just kind of trust people
much smarter than you that they have
these,
these good ideas that sometimes conflict
and.
But you'll never really know the answer.
It's,
it's so frustrating to me.
Those ideas definitely do conflict here.
This is the area that he looked over
here,
place them in,
so you get some volume on this.
Probably Brian,
based upon the president flood,
he had the flood that a few days a week
whenever they would not have been washed
away,
a long,
long detailed thing.
I mean he's talked about on the podcast
for hours and hours.
I've had them on several times and it's
still.
There's still a lot of information to
cover because this guy has been studying
this as whole life.
I'm going to look into that.
That sounds interesting to me.
Absolutely positive that humans had an
impact on wooly mammoths and a lot of
other animals,
but there's a lot of people that are
very,
very hesitant to blame the entire
radication of these animals on people.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't know enough about it.
I do recommend the book though.
Digit.
Just an interesting insight into a 1491.
It's called just an interesting insight
into,
into agriculture and so just some ideas
that kind of cobbled together some sort
of like vision of this place before,
you know,
mainstream European contact because
obviously a few places that I would.
I mean if you had a time machine and
we've always thought about this,
like if you could go in some sort of an
invisible bubble and experience the
earth at various stages.
There's two,
two things I would love to see.
I would love to see during the great
pyramids,
like when,
when they were in their prime,
I would love to see what it,
what was Egypt actually like before they
burned the library of Alexandria and I
would have loved to have seen a native
tribe in North America.
Pre colonization.
Right.
It'd be fascinating and that's the
frustrating thing is we'll never really
quite know the answer,
but it's.
It's fun to speculate about and I was
reading it.
I think you'd find interesting.
I was reading about the Easter islanders
and how they have.
They have sweet potatoes on the island
which are not indigenous to the island
and the sweet potato to kind of spread
around Polynesia,
presumably from South America
and there's this interesting thing that
the name,
the word,
I don't remember the exact word,
but the word that many Polynesians are.
Many Polynesian societies that were
separated from each other.
Use for the sweet potato is identical to
what they were using on the South
American mainland indicating that the,
the.
The islands might've been populated from
the other direction that they assume
that people came down from like what is
I guess like Indonesia and to Australia
and then kind of hopped over to those
islands.
But people are suggesting that there
must've been contact from Paleo
Americans on those islands because they
eat sweet potatoes which are indigenous
to South America and they call them the
same exact thing.
That the societies that we're thousands
of miles apart,
um,
had,
had experienced,
and you hear a lot about a lot of this
was there cross transatlantic contact,
could that,
and then it gets into crazy like
conspiracy theories about the pyramids
and stuff,
but were there with the phoenicians come
over where,
where the Egyptian contact to the
Chinese come here that the Romans,
I remember that there was this,
uh,
this theory that Romans might've been on
the Pacific coast of North America
because they found,
um,
I guess they apparently found some
coins,
Roman coins and they found these jars
that I guess were ancient Roman are or
supposedly ancient Roman anchors for
sure.
I've seen that.
That was,
these are recent discoveries.
I think so over the last 10 years maybe.
Yeah.
I mean the human history is,
it's,
you know,
kind of pieced together by what we find
and every now and then they find
something,
they go,
oh,
okay.
You know,
I mean,
what's really crazy is that the native
Americans,
when the settlers got here,
when Europeans got here,
they didn't have horses,
but horses actually evolved in North
America.
Horses evolved in North America and then
by crossing the bering land mass made
their way into Asia and all throughout
the rest of the world.
Even zebras,
they originally started in North America
wild,
but then somehow or another,
so for some reason they went extinct in
North America and you know,
they survived and thrived in Europe and
then they were reintroduced and Dan
Flores,
he's a wildlife historian.
He maintains that the native Americans
once,
once they had firearms and the horse,
that they would have wiped out the
buffalo on their own.
That it had nothing to do with like
market hunting and all the things that
the Europeans did was terrible and it
happened quite rapidly,
but he maintains that it was,
it was gonna happen anyway.
Just just the nature of what kind of an
animal it was and that humans were
eventually going to get to them anyway.
Yeah,
I mean that's what we were talking
about,
the human condition and how things don't
seem to change regardless of who you're
talking about.
And I'm always fascinated by these
gentle kind of connections between these
different societies that we're learning
more and more about that the world is
way smaller than I think we thought it
was in antiquity.
And even before that,
um,
they were talking about how some
greenland and Newfoundland and New
Brunswick and all of these kind of had
these Indian tribes that definitely
probably had extended contact with the
vikings for a long period of time.
And,
and these words kind of find their way
to like the St Lawrence Valley that
describe the same things.
And then when the French fur traders
come,
they find that they're using words that
they shouldn't know.
And yeah,
it's,
it's super fascinating.
Like the,
these,
these brilliant scholars that kind of
put these things together for us to
write about.
It is amazing,
you know,
and just think of how much we don't
know.
I mean God to be able to go back 60,000
years ago and just be a fly on the wall
and some ancient civilization and see
how they interact with each other.
Oh,
awesome.
That will be honest with you even read
about.
There were these great,
there's outside of St Louis,
I think it's like Cahokia or something
like that.
It was this massive native American
metropolis in North America.
We often think about central and South
America is having these may,
Aztec,
Inca,
all these major cities,
but there were major mountain cities in
North America that were populated by
maybe 25,
30,000
people and they were wiped out before we
even got here or before our European
ancestors got here.
Um,
and it's so god,
you're right,
because it would just be so interesting
to see how,
how do they live,
how do they farm,
how,
what was their commerce lake,
um,
you know,
what was their languages like,
did they,
did they have written records that
didn't survive?
And I don't know.
But again,
that ties back into a venn diagram of
frustration because you'll never really
know.
There's a ranch up in central California
that I go to sometimes called to hone
ranch.
And there's these stone circles that are
carved in rocks.
So they have these massive rocks.
And then there's like these concave,
like dug outs where they would make
bread.
So you're,
you're looking at places where they
would grind grain into these rocks and
these holes are,
you know,
who knows how long they existed,
who knows how long ago these subsistence
farmers or subsistence,
uh,
people lived there and did this.
And so you're,
you're stepping over these rocks and
staring down on.
There's some getty images of him.
Those holes were carved by the native
Americans and they were done over
fucking years and years of grinding
stones into the stone.
And know what's interesting is a lot of
the ancient Egyptians I went to see the
mummy exhibit at the Natural National
Natural History Museum or the Science
Museum.
Which one is it in California?
Anyway,
they had a museum exhibit on mummies and
they said all their teeth were ground
down and it's because when they would
make their bread and they would grind
stone and the stone,
it would create sand and that sand would
be in the bread interested to be eating
this gritty sandy bread.
And that's,
that's what they ate.
And they would just chew their fucking
teeth away to nothing.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
it's,
it's this marriage of archeology and
anthropology and sociology.
Even that gives.
I'm always disconcerted that more people
don't find this fascinating.
You're a real student of history.
I mean,
you really love history.
I do.
I love it.
I mean,
I thought that was a really interesting
subject when you and I were talking the
first time you,
you and you were a young guy,
but you embrace it,
you know,
I think it's fascinating.
Someone has to do it.
It's not,
it's not practical.
I always tell people people have gone,
you know,
over the years,
fans of mine have gone to school for
history and asked me should I study
history and politics and I'm like,
you can,
I think you should do what makes you
happy.
I think it would be much wiser for you
to study pharmacy or chemistry or
something.
And there's not a lot of money in
history.
Yeah,
there's nothing.
I mean,
I remember when I was about to start
Grad school when I,
um,
when I got my job in the gaming industry
and I left and um,
I remember,
uh,
professors being like 50 percent of all
history phd is,
will never find a job in the field 50
percent because there's no,
it's the same thing with archeology.
Like I played around with the idea of
doing like a American archeology,
which is a growing movement.
They're digging up Jamestown there,
the,
you know,
all those kinds of things and there's
just no money in it,
you know.
Um,
and so I,
I try to just,
I want people to just love history,
like the way I love it and understand
it.
And I think a lot of it is because it's
not told well it's not.
The stories dates and times are
interesting.
I remember them and I think I have that
kind of brain,
that right,
that kind of right centered brain where
like,
I remember facts and dates,
but that's not really what's important
about it.
And if people taught history Morris
stories than which I think is what I'm
trying to do with my show,
then I think that people will enjoy it
more.
So I think that's like the greatest
pleasure of what I do with people saying
like,
I hate history.
I hated history of God.
I thought it was so boring,
but this is such,
this is so interesting.
Thank you for bringing this to my
attention.
And I was like,
well,
you know,
more power to you and now we can
remember what happened in these stories
are interesting and they're important.
They are important in how many people
are taking advantage of that?
How many people are passing these
stories around?
I mean,
how many Dan Carlin's are there in the
world?
Yeah.
Not many.
And pretty much.
No.
One of his skill.
Yeah.
Hey Jamie can be one of them.
Caveman's please.
And another one of these jammies.
You want to caveman coffee?
Want to get jazzed up?
I'm okay.
Thank you.
I don't drink coffee.
You don't drink coffee?
I just don't know.
Not.
I have no problem with.
I just don't drink it.
You just don't like the taste.
It's not getting jacked.
Oh No,
I don't mind.
I don't mind getting.
Yeah,
I could do some energy,
but.
No,
I'm good.
Thank you.
I always feel like I'm missing out on
something because people really love it.
Like my girlfriend's the same way.
My Dad Super Coffee Connoisseur.
Yeah,
he loves it.
He loves coffee and like feel like that
would cigarette sometimes.
I know cigarettes are terrible for you
and I think they smell gross,
but I see people taking a big drag of
the cigarette and he seems so satisfied
and excited by it.
I'm like,
hmm,
maybe I'm missing something.
Yeah,
I always see.
I always see people outside of work in
my neighborhood.
You kind of get to know the characters
in your neighborhood.
Right.
And they're always standing outside
smoking,
you know,
having a little more time.
I'll tell you what though.
I,
I smoked one of Tony Hinchcliffe
cigarettes before a show once a,
I think I've done it twice now.
And uh,
you,
your,
it's a real cognitive booster.
I mean,
it really does stimulate you in a very
strange way.
Thank you,
sir.
Do you think you were better when you
after,
after having what's better?
I don't know.
Sometimes you're not bitter stimulated.
Especially doing standup.
Sometimes you're better balanced and
calm you,
but it's
mentally,
it's,
it definitely stimulates you in some
sort of a weird way.
I was like,
whew.
So like a different sort of feeling.
It's like if you ever smoked a cigar.
Yeah,
yeah.
You get high off cigar.
Yeah.
I can only smoke half of it or actually
start to get like almost nauseous.
So yeah,
you get high,
like the nicotine and a fat stokey
definitely gets you high.
There's something to it.
It makes me think about these old,
these old timers are people still do it,
but my friend growing up,
his GRANDPA would always.
That smell reminds me of him because
he'd always just sit on the porch and
smoke,
but it just chain smoke like cigars.
And how are you not animals people.
It's incredible.
I uh,
but yeah,
I.
How is uh,
you were doing the sober thing for the
sober October.
So today's the last day.
How do you feel about saying I'm nervous
devers smoke pot again?
Tell you that God,
I haven't gotten more than two days
without smoking pot in 15 years,
so I don't even know.
It's weird.
I'll tell you the big,
the big change is your sleep.
You have radical dreams.
Really?
Yeah.
Radical.
Really realistic.
I'm confusing.
Dreams were in the middle of the dream.
You don't realize that it's a dream.
Like I had a dream that I was lying on
this couch,
a couch that actually exists a couch in
my house and that I was cold so I
grabbed this blanket and I was pulling
the blanket over me,
but the blanket was kind of stuck in the
pillows so you know,
like kind of struggled with it and get
the blanket over you.
And then I woke up and there's no
fucking blanket.
I was like,
oh my God.
Like I dreamt that I was pulling a
blanket.
I mean,
it was so realistic that I would have
sworn if I woke up that I had struggled
to get that blanket over me while I was
taking a nap on the couch,
but there was no fucking blanket I was
reading and as I was reading I decided I
was going to lie down right here and
sleep and I must have passed out and
decided that I was cold and went through
this elaborate dream sequence where I
pulled a blanket over me,
but I was convinced that I had woken up
cold and had to adjust and pull the
blanket over me and went back to sleep.
It's mainly very vivid,
fucking super vivid,
but there was no blanket anywhere near
me when I woke up.
I mean there's just fucking couch
pillow.
That's it.
No blanket on the ground.
Not to like I could have gotten up and
put it over there and sleep walk.
There's no fucking blanket.
But in my mind if you had asked me like,
did you wake up and pull a blanket over
it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
I remember.
No,
I don't remember.
Shit.
It was fake.
Are you,
so are you looking forward to not doing
this anymore or are you kind of like,
or do you want to keep,
keep doing it?
Like are the benefits or the pros
outweigh the cons?
I think there are real creative benefits
to marijuana.
I do too.
There's um,
there's states that I think you achieve
when you smoke pot that are unattainable
without pot.
I think pot makes me more introspective.
It makes me nicer.
It makes me calmer.
It makes me a,
I have a better sense and understanding
of like the importance and value of
community.
It makes me more sensitive to the things
that I'm saying,
you know?
Um,
I don't,
I don't think pods bad not.
I think it's always good to take time
away from anything just to get a better
baseline to bring yourself back down to
neutral.
Yeah.
I feel like I,
it's something that maybe I should
challenge myself to do as well because I
remember,
I mean I've been,
I've smoked marijuana regularly my whole
adult life and it becomes the,
some people dip in and out of it.
Like,
it's something that you do
recreationally or you want to get stoned
before a concert or whatever.
But I always found that it was,
uh,
it was,
as,
as sad as it sounds.
Some people,
I think that it was almost part of my
process in a way where even in college I
was writing a paper or as working or,
or whatever the case might be.
You know,
I feel like,
yeah,
let's take a take a smoke a joint or
something like that.
And,
and I agree.
Like I,
I get most creative to this day,
late at night when I,
if I smoke or do something like that,
um,
I'm writing good stuff,
I'm having good ideas.
I'm writing ideas down and then
sometimes they come back to them later
when I'm not stone and I can flesh them
out more or whatever.
But I agree that there's great.
Um,
there's great creative benefit to it.
And I also feel like I'm really happy
that in a very short amount of time,
uh,
American society has come around to the
benefits of marijuana,
not only medicinally,
but just recreationally.
And the number is the polling numbers
from the early two thousands to today
are radically different.
We're talking about ships,
I'm like 30,
35 points and how people feel about them
and I'm like,
any,
like you're saying like with anything in
moderation is probably key.
I often in my life don't because it can
make me lazy too.
We can get me very interested in music
or something like that and I get
distracted.
So in my general day to day I don't
smoke until I'm done with what I like
the administrative shit I need to do.
I'm done.
I,
I've gone to the grocery store,
I've done all of these things.
Okay.
Now it's time for me to relax.
You know,
your grunt work.
Exactly.
And so,
uh,
so.
But do you have like a,
do you have a,
like a specific joint or something
strand ready that you want to smoke when
to get back into it?
Are you gonna ease back into it?
Are you gonna?
Are you gonna pull?
It just says Jamie just pulled something
up.
Holes of PSA.
Find supportive legal weed and an all
time high.
That's great.
Yeah,
no,
I just,
I'm just going to smoke some pot.
I'm gonna do it tomorrow with Owen
Benjamin or doing a podcast together,
so I'm going to get high for the first
time on air.
Nice.
So that'll be interesting for the
audience.
Yeah.
Should be interesting for me to um,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm a little nervous because I know it's
going to hit me like a damn a bet.
My tolerance is down to zero,
but that's gonna be fun for you because
now you'll,
you'll,
yeah,
because I do feel like there's a plateau
obviously.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Like heavy duty,
hardcore daytime stoners,
you know,
they don't,
they don't feel anything.
Yeah.
It's almost like a,
it's almost like sustaining some sort of
feeling but you're not,
you can never reach that.
That feeling again,
which is again,
why moderation is important and it's the
same thing.
Alcoholics frankly feeling other
people's views,
things so,
but marijuana,
we have a very infant style sort of
approach to what marijuana is because
of,
I think because of the all the
prohibition bullshit that people went
through from the 19 thirties on.
There's this,
you know,
this weird propaganda that,
that marijuana is the devil's weed and
it's terrible for you.
There's a lot of like cultural and
societal benefits to achieving those
states of mind.
I think they really do make people
nicer.
You know,
I think it,
it calms you down.
It May.
Here's the big one that everybody's
worried about.
Paranoia.
It makes you paranoid.
I don't think that that's.
I don't think that that's a bad thing
necessarily.
I think that paranoia,
that feeling of vulnerability,
it probably makes you more honestly
assess how you interface with the world.
You know,
there's a lot of real danger in the
world,
you know,
and I think that marijuana probably
makes you really think about that real
danger in a way that you perhaps ignore
or put in the back of your head,
but it's always there.
It's always there in your subconscious
to sorta grinding away.
Whereas marijuana brings it to the
front,
has a light shines that light on it
goes,
hey,
maybe she'll look at this.
How about the fact that your lungs don't
work so good anymore,
man?
How many more years you got?
Many more summers you think you'd have
on this planet,
you know you've got 40,
you got 15,
you got 60.
That's it.
If you're lucky,
if you're lucky you got 60,
but you're right.
It's fascinating because if it.
If it opens up these places in our brain
that are creative that let us write
better,
that make us funnier and with your
comedy for instance,
or whatever the case might be,
then you know it makes you kinder,
which I agree.
It makes me a people out.
Then of course it would make sense that
it opens up these dark recesses in your
brain that hide or shield these things
that you don't want to think about and I
agree that confronting those things is
normal.
I think a paranoia I think is a is a
side effect of marijuana for sure,
but it's about how you harness it and if
you think about it within the terms that
in the parameters that you're talking
about it,
which is that these things exist.
So you're just thinking about.
It's not like you're.
It's not a manifestation of something
that doesn't exist.
No.
And it makes you aware of some things
that are very easy to ignore but are
pretty fucking huge like space.
Like my.
One of my favorite things to do is a
smoke a joint and go out and sit in my
backyard,
has pull up a lawn chair,
put my feet up and just stare up at
space and just think of how fucking
insane it is that there is this in
immeasurable view of infinity and it's
above our head and we sort of take it
for granted and we barely stare at it.
We barely look at it.
We barely taken into consideration.
It's just,
it's just a thing that we completely
take for granted.
But when I'm high I can really freak out
about it.
It can get to.
One of the things I like to do when I
smoke a little pot is get to the base of
a hill.
There's something about being in the
base of a hill and lying down where
you're looking up and you see the hill
and then you see the clouds moving over
the hill in the background,
the blue sky and the clouds.
There's something about that that gives
me a more accurate understanding of
atmosphere of this thin layer of
protective air that keeps us shielded
from radiation,
the magnetosphere above all this
stuff that that's above us.
That's just sort of like slowly moving
around this just this giant globe is
that there's that view where you're
laying back and you're looking up at the
clouds rolling over the top of the
mountain.
It gives you like a more of an
understanding of the spiritual nature of
the planet and the fact that it is
draped in this atmosphere.
There's just a real weird,
trippy reset sort of a feeling that I
get from that.
Like we're on like a convertible
spaceship.
Yeah.
It's,
it is remarkable that it brings,
it brings memories forward of like that,
that rare earth hypothesis.
The idea that we might not necessarily
be alone,
but this is so unique that maybe it's
worth,
you know,
the um,
the,
what was it that Harvard professor that
did the mathematical equation of how if
we're alone or not army parents.
Yeah.
Like where he gives us kind of numbers
to various things and,
and uh,
the suggestion there is that we probably
life based on the confines of a,
of a 13 point 5 billion year old
universe that is expanding at the speed
of light is probably that we're not very
alone,
but the idea that light this planet with
just this and just the right place with
a moon that protects it from a lot of
ancient astroid and comic collisions
that I'm with oxygen and it's just so
fascinating and I think that we often
don't think like in a weird way
galactically about are universally about
like how everything that we experience
is based on our experience on this
little globe hurdling through space as
temporary life forms.
It's.
Yeah.
And I,
I like it because it,
it removes this to me.
I'm an atheist.
I don't believe in God.
And I,
I feel like that's liberating in a
sense.
I don't mind if people of faith,
I come from a family that,
you know,
Catholics and they don't agree with me,
but that,
that you almost let go and just be like,
we're here.
We have a finite amount of time.
It's probably a mistake that were here
are some sort of just random occurrence
and it,
it's liberating because you used the
time you have to do what you want to do
and then you're gone.
Ashes to ashes and I and a lot of people
look at the ashes to ashes as like this
dark thing and I'm like,
it's kind of Nice.
It's kind of interesting,
you know,
like,
like what's here is gone.
What will be,
is made from what you are,
you know?
Well,
people absolutely terrified of the idea
that they're not going to be around to
experience something.
You know?
It's weird because everybody's afraid to
die,
but no one's afraid to sleep.
That's,
that's deep.
And it's true.
I mean,
I,
I hope that I get to see things.
I feel like one of the things that I'm,
I'm bummed about for our,
for the time in which we live,
you and I,
is that I feel like we're in this middle
space where some crazy shit's going to
happen in probably 2100 and beyond.
When we really start exploring space and
what's happening right now,
I think we're at the embryonic state of
crazy things happening and I,
I,
we might,
you know,
think about how far we've come even in
the last 15 years,
so who knows,
but the idea of traveling to other star
systems,
the idea of meeting life,
man,
imagine how frustrated you would be if a
contact like situation Jodie foster,
Carl Sagan like situation happened while
you're on your deathbed.
Yeah.
Or even if you have 20 years left and
they don't give you this,
this radical mathematical equation of
build a spaceship,
but they're just like,
hey,
we're here and we're 150 light years
away and,
and you have to literally take 150 years
to send that message.
It will take that long to send the
message back and then another 150 years
to get the message back and so on and so
forth.
What if they're all like Putin's Russian
mob,
but in space.
You know what I mean?
He's this idea that they're going to be
some sort of altruistic,
beautiful alien race that's gotten past
war.
And what if it's like a race of Harvey
Weinstein's out.
The university's creditable.
They come here a mouth fuck us off.
I mean,
who knows what,
why they would care about us.
I mean,
I'm also,
there's this assumption that they would
treat us better than the way we treat
monkeys that we find in the Congo
because we don't treat primates very
well.
Well,
it is funny how that's true.
We don't treat almost anything very well
except for our dogs and our cats.
But the,
the um,
it is funny to think about this kind of,
these kinds of thought experiments that
people do and [inaudible] and whatever
about what,
what would be the,
why would they come and what would be
the nature of them and what is their,
you know,
why are they taking the initiative to
contact us?
And it,
it's interesting that a lot of people do
settle on the.
They,
if they're going through this trouble,
they're not coming here to,
to fuck with you.
Like silly.
But I think like,
why not,
you know,
I don't know.
Why would you make an assumption based
on human understanding of anything,
what they're gonna do you know if this
is a very.
In terms of like resources,
this,
this planet.
It's very rich,
you know?
I mean think about it.
What if there are from a planet that's
low in water,
we're three quarters water.
The surface of our planet is mostly
water,
right?
We have all sorts of weird minerals and
who knows how,
I mean,
they're rare in our solar system.
So what we find on earth in terms of the
biological life is insane,
right?
We haven't even found biological life
anywhere else in the solar system.
So it could be that this is just the
ultimate fucking sweet spot.
I mean we are in what we call the
goldilocks zone,
right?
But then there's also,
my thought is always why just like it's
such a limited thing to think that
biological life as we know at carbon
based life on the planet earth that
exists between the temperatures of x and
y,
you know,
and it has a lifespan of whatever the
fuck it is.
Like there's the only way life can be
like,
why?
Yeah.
No,
I never bought that.
I always was confused by that.
Why can a species breathe ammonia?
Yeah.
And you know,
like I,
and that's why they use the term,
I guess a life as we know it.
Uh,
but I'm,
I'm of the same mind as you,
I think with just the mathematical
permutations,
you know,
multiplied by the amount of space
covered.
Even the exoplanets we're finding now,
I know a lot of them are gas giants and
stuff like that and the really close to
the star system,
but they indicate that maybe we're not
all so unique.
And I was reading a thing about Jupiter
and Saturn even in relation to
exoplanets being found that are similar
to them that they might have been far
closer to the sun when they formed.
Then we're pushed out.
So maybe we're seeing solar systems
earlier on in their,
in their lifecycle.
And,
and there's a lot of.
I love space,
do I?
I think it's a super fascinating study.
I wish that I was smarter with math,
with physics and all those kinds of
things so they have a very,
very limited understanding of that
stuff,
you know,
like the,
um,
that maybe I would have explored that
instead,
but I don't have that,
but my brain doesn't work like that,
you know,
I can't do calculus.
Are you a fan of science fiction?
Yes.
Do you like,
did you like the Battlestar Galactica
series?
Loved it.
Great.
It's awesome.
One of the most underrated series ever.
It was awesome.
I knew one.
Yeah.
The one from 2004.
I,
uh,
I loved it because,
I think it married really well.
Saifai believable Saifai with,
um,
the problems we're encountering maybe
with ai now with the cylons and then a
religious aspect,
a monotheistic polytheistic cultures
kind of clashing,
a lot of,
there's a lot of depth to that that I
think people don't see because they're
turned off by the setting.
But I think a lot of people just missed
it because it was a retake of a.
was in 1977 or [inaudible] 79,
1987 with that.
Yeah.
It was a retake of that show.
That seemed to be at the time to be a
star wars rip off,
you know,
it was like,
there was like,
you're luke skywalker character that was
starbuck,
you know,
there's all this,
there was all this stuff to it that
people like,
ah,
that's a fake storm trooper.
This show sucks.
I know it was a movie.
Yeah,
it was the show rather.
it was.
Yeah,
it started as a,
uh,
like a mini series,
which is about the cylons turning on the
humans and then,
or I guess the end result of them
turning on the humans.
And then,
uh,
and then they expanded into four
seasons,
I think.
I think the show is amazing and show.
Was it only four seasons?
Yeah,
I think it was 2000.
Four to 2009 or something like that.
Bringing it back.
Come on fuckers.
Netflix,
get on it.
Come on.
I know it's canceled on house of cards.
Give us some Battlestar Galactica.
Battlestar was great.
I thought that they,
they told the arc really well.
Fascinating.
I thought the acting was pretty good.
Um,
and uh,
I liked the idea of the,
because we're dealing with it
tangentially now.
The uh,
the idea of,
not that it's unique to that story,
but of ai and robots turning on,
you know,
like it's very smart.
People were telling us that that's very
possible.
And so we should probably start
listening to them.
Well,
it is possible.
Of course it's possible.
I think we could be a new life form.
I mean,
I really do believe that.
I think we're either probably going to
be augmented by these creations and you
know,
we're gonna choose to take on new body
parts that function much better than the
body parts we have now,
or we're,
you know,
essentially laboring to create some
thing that's going to surpass us that,
that absolutely could be at this idea
that it's artificial to say,
well,
it's right there.
It's real.
Like if it's a life form,
oh,
it's artificial life.
No,
it's electronic life.
You know,
it's something that humans have created,
but it's still life.
It doesn't like if you take a plant,
right.
You know,
I was looking at these plants and they
splice different plants together.
Like they splice pistachios into
Avocados.
They have like the base of anodic,
avocado tree and pistachios are grown on
the outside.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
That's wild.
I didn't know you could do that.
Yeah.
Well is that artificial?
What is that?
It seems like it's artificial life.
I mean,
it seems like they've figured out some
way to engineer things in a crude sense,
you know,
by splicing and grafting and doing all
these different weird things to plants.
Well,
that's it still life though,
right?
It's still alive.
It's functional.
And we,
we think of life as a boy,
he has to have bones or blood or scales
or fins says who zou says us and our
limited sort of vocabulary and are very,
very limited encyclopedia of variables
that we allow to,
to consider life.
Yeah.
I think.
I think you're right because we have to
judge maybe life based on consciousness
instead of.
I'm not that a plant would have
consciousness,
but I think that's the kind of the
ethical questions we're going to start
coming up with,
with machines in the next 20 or 30 years
is,
are you developing something?
It,
there's actually a great.
I don't want to ruin it for you.
There's an amazing black mirror that
kind of touches on this.
It's called a,
I think it's called White Christmas.
You should check it out if you have
time.
And uh,
Hamm is actually the main character in
it from admin and it,
the idea that like if something is
conscious,
even if it's not real or even if it's
only in a computer,
um,
what does that mean?
And what if the,
what if it was trapped there,
what if it didn't have agency over its
life,
but it was still conscious and stuff
like that,
like you were messing with things that
we don't understand in this regard
because even the word consciousness
doesn't really have a concrete
definition.
We could,
we don't even know what it is.
We are conscious,
my dogs conscious,
but are they self conscious and,
and at what level of consciousness and
that's what makes us human.
So if we're going to implant that into
other machines,
even if they're just computers,
even if they're literally just running
on an operating system,
then then there are,
there are definitely gonna be ethical
questions to ask,
I think.
Do you,
did you see that Google situation they
had were the two computers were
communicating each other into a,
with a language that they invent?
I read about that.
Yeah.
I saw,
I read a little bit about that,
but I don't know
about it.
Yeah,
they shut it down.
Like what?
Yeah,
it's horrifying,
right?
It's happening so much quicker than.
Yeah,
talk.
I mean we,
we,
we've envisioned these things is like
skynet or the cylons or something like
that,
but I think it's gonna be much more
quaint.
Yeah,
that's
what they were very stunned by this and
you know,
I saw somebody trying to diminishing it,
trying to diminish it,
and he was like,
well,
it's just ones and Zeros.
It's just like,
what they're doing the communicating
once a year.
I was like,
yeah,
but they are talking,
exchanging information back and forth in
a method that we don't understand and
they do.
How the fuck do they and why have they
chosen talk to each other.
And is this like one,
you know,
you have like a science fiction movie at
the beginning of the movie.
You have these engineers sitting around
and the engineer's going on,
Mike,
come here and look at this real quick.
They're talking to each other.
What do you mean the target to each
other that?
Well,
there's,
there's a language,
this is,
see this,
see,
this is an here and here's the answer
and here's the response to the answer
and here they have agreed upon this and
now they've expanded their sentences,
like,
shut it down.
Just shut it down.
Just what,
what do,
what do we do about this?
Let's let it play out.
No,
no,
let's shut it down.
Let's talk about this.
And then they shut it down and it fades
to black.
Cut to smash.
Cut.
Like you see a new time to 20,
34.
And it's some Dystopian Mad Max plucking
world and robot.
People are running down the street
chasing after biological people wanting
to use them for fuel.
Well,
it's interesting.
It's interesting because there are
different,
um,
there are different reasons why a robot
or a machine might turn on you,
right?
Like I,
I think the cylons were interesting
because they turned because they were
enslaved,
right?
So that was,
there was vengeance,
which is a human quality by the way.
An animal doesn't really understand
vengeance,
but a robots do do.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess about higher primates or
whatever,
I might understand a retaliatory kind of
thing,
but generally this is a human quality,
right?
And um,
what's a primate primary?
Primary quality.
And uh,
so there's that,
but so there's like this enslavement,
retaliation kind of thing going on.
But then there's the very like,
um,
what I always find fascinating,
and I think this is more what skynet was
all about in terminator,
although I don't really remember,
is the idea that if you look at,
if you look at the landscape of what's
happening and you and you just remove
the most inefficient part of it,
it's the human.
Like in other words,
I'm acting as they are machines like
this.
This doesn't make any sense.
This makes our processing slower.
This particular component needs to be
removed.
So there's a very logical reason why
they would go after you to.
I think it's,
it is the stuff of Scifi,
but like so many things that start in
Saifai,
it ends up bleeding into,
into real life.
And I think it's a.
When I see people like Stephen Hawking,
Bill Gates,
Elon Musk all talking about this,
I'm like,
these are some of the smartest people
that society has ever given us and I
think we might want to pay attention and
have some.
I think what they want is some sort of
congress,
not,
not American Congress,
but some sort of international coalition
that agrees this is what we're going to
do and this is how far will push the
boundaries because I'm and I just don't
know that we'll get there before it's,
I don't want to say before it's too
late,
but before we have a,
a scary situation.
I mean and even from a mechanical
situation,
what they're doing at Boston dynamics is
fucking horrifying.
Crazy.
I look at the videos and I'm like,
what the.
And there.
It's so funny because some people had
said in the past like if you see them
like they're,
they're using hockey sticks a lot to
like beat them or like take like knock
something out of their hands and stuff.
And I'm like,
these are the videos they're going to
show.
They're going to show them in their and
their military camps when they're
turning on humanity.
There's so many different verses of them
they haven't looked at.
They looked like cheetahs.
They have them that looked like dogs.
I mean,
here's look like people consistently.
Yeah.
And these guys are just constantly
working on these things too and
constantly improve.
Where is Boston dynamics?
Is it.
I think it's,
I think it's in Cambridge because I
think a lot of people,
I think a lot of people at,
uh,
mit might migrate there and I think
Google owned them,
but I think they've divested,
if I remember correctly.
That is so wild.
Yeah.
And the ones where they like knock them
over and they get up.
Yeah.
The kid.
That's what.
Yeah.
Like because the gyroscope is going I
guess.
And it's.
Yeah.
Gyroscopes are fascinating,
you know,
just something that can sort of self
balance this.
They're going to show them in like the
hype them up in their propaganda.
Yeah.
It's fucking amazing.
It is,
it is amazing.
I mean these are,
these are so smart,
these people that do that.
I managed to do this.
Don't you want to pull them aside and
go,
hey man,
what's the fucking end game?
Yeah,
like they're all want to play with
robot.
You can't kick over.
Come on dude.
It brings up,
um,
it,
it brings up how will we fight wars in
the future we'll be doing with this 100
percent.
Yeah.
Especially for fight some war with some
sort of a primitive culture.
I like how they have unbalanced with all
these packs and creates incredible,
like highlight clip of all the times
they've abused the robot.
Is that what this is?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
The robot general right now has this
plane behind him and as he's talking and
he's like,
remember what they've done to your
ancestors will,
they're saying abuse,
but they're checking tolerances.
You know the scene to relax.
This is how we made you so awesome.
You've dumb fuck you.
Stupid perks.
He can't even walk on ice.
Now.
The interesting thing,
the interesting thing to me about this
is,
and I don't know if you feel,
but I kind of do it,
like when they're tripping and falling,
I have this feeling of like I have this
feeling of like,
yeah,
we're like,
oh,
you know what I mean?
Look at this poor guy.
Yeah,
you feel bad for him.
He can't even kick this one over.
Wow.
That thing is stout.
Yeah.
I mean,
so they have multiple different models.
The video name is funny,
by the way,
Jamie.
That's literally to every time Boston
dynamics has abused the robot.
It's not abuse you dummies.
It's fucking tested because how they
find out of that nerd that's kicking it
over.
Go back to that guy.
Oh,
that thing sucks.
Go back to that one guy that was kicking
it.
Look at him.
He's like,
looks like he just came back and
everybody don't feel back.
Go back to him so he could see him do
it.
Watching fucking piece of shit.
He's like,
look like.
He always wanted to kick some butt
projecting like even with this little
tiny short steps like you seemed awkward
before.
He kicks it.
I'm going to kick it nano.
Look at this one.
Oh,
it's balancing on one leg and then
hitting it with a 20 pound medicine
ball.
Wow.
Yeah.
We're,
we're in for a weird hundred years.
Yes.
And that's what I'm saying.
I hope that we get to see some because I
think it's going to get fucking crazy.
Yeah,
no,
there's no doubt.
It is.
No doubt it is.
It's just like how crazy and what's
going to be the issues that were in the
have to confront sentient life and,
and,
and also the real question is,
will it have any motivation to advance
the idea is that the real fear is that
these things are going to be so hyper
intelligent that they're going to be
able to create a much better version of
themselves fairly quickly.
Like as soon as you give them autonomy
and as soon as they're sentient,
you're,
you're going to say,
oh,
okay,
make a better one.
Make it better with the new.
And this is you guys fucked up here.
Like why have all these shitty
connections and let's do it this way and
let's do it that way and let's connect
to each other through you guys use in
Wifi version six this week,
like what we need is this new form of
Wifi that it uses the particles in the
atmosphere as transistors and and sends
back and forth to each other through a
highly charged signal and like what?
Yeah,
it's how'd you figure that out?
And then next thing you know,
but they,
they're not going to have ego.
They're not going to have this desire
for and this is.
This is a real underlying aspect.
The motivation of the human race,
the desire to recreate and to reproduce
like this desire for sex and this desire
to.
It's one of the reasons why people
accomplish things.
They don't just accomplish things
because they have this desire to see
what happens when they put these two
things together and what's the result
they want.
They want fame,
they want status,
they want power,
they want money,
and they want all these things because
they want to be more sexually
attractive.
That's a big part of the motivation of
men,
you know,
so it's a weird thing.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why Jeff Bezos
doesn't just retire.
Why doesn't Jeff Bezos when he just
became the richest man in the world,
how the fuck you going to spend $90,
million dollars homes to cash out,
cash out and just chillax forever.
You know,
just walk around with a big red wig on
so nobody knows who you are and just
live like a king,
like go wherever you want,
fuck all this work and you're waking up
in the morning freaking out about Amazon
and making sure everything gets
delivered in 30 minutes or less like a
fucking pizza instead just live.
But no,
no way.
Jeff Bezos has a fucking supermodel
girlfriend now.
He's bawling.
Every good jumped from one gold
Lamborghini to the next one.
I mean,
you start thinking,
I want more.
I want this,
I want that whole.
What is the motivation to do something
like that?
Where's it coming from in men?
I think a lot of it comes from this
need.
I mean,
I think if you brought it down to the
base level,
it's this weird biological need to
reproduce or to spread your genes or to
be to stand out as something
particularly impressive your peacocking
for,
for females and a lot of ways,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
there is,
there has been a stud.
I know.
It is amazing to me where I'm like,
I dream every day about how I can retire
as quickly as possible and then these
guys that have the means to do it don't.
But there isn't an internal drive with
guys.
I mean you don't found a company like
Amazon unless there's something special
about you and I don't mean that as a
derogatory thing either.
Like there's something about a person.
Ironic is it's,
it was originally founded to sell books.
It just was a very simple site.
Have you ever seen the original Amazon?
Yeah.
You can go to the wayback machine and
look at all that.
Yeah.
To
really simple site to sell books and I
remember when Amazon starts
selling other things,
I was like,
what are they doing that they sell
books?
Why are you selling like fucking kids
toys?
Yeah.
They moved into music and then I think
they'd been to,
they started expanding from there.
It's funny though.
You brought up the,
uh,
you know,
the robots making better versions of
themselves.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
not to be nerdy about,
but that's exactly what happens in
Battlestar.
Like what comes,
what comes back,
the fight the humans is not what left,
right.
And uh,
because they just were like,
we're not good enough.
We can make ourselves better and made
those killer ones that looked like
people,
right?
Yeah.
The number that number's wherever they
call them.
And then even like,
um,
and even the centurions look better or
more effective in their soldiers.
And there's that one episode about the
raiders,
which is their ships.
They have these autonomous ships that
are alive,
that are fighter ships and uh,
and uh,
how they,
one of them is named scar and he keeps
having these experiences.
Like he's really a good fighter pilot or
whatever,
but he's alive.
And then it's like,
it's really good fucking show.
Goddamn.
Bring it back.
If you guys out there,
you have such a great audience that
would,
oh my God,
you go check it out the numbers or spike
on that Netflix,
they'll see it and then they'll be like,
oh,
maybe will be if,
if folks,
if you haven't seen it,
I'm telling you it is a.
and I think it was psi Phi that made it.
It was like a [inaudible],
like coming to kind of like that.
It was a legitimate thing that they did
and it was very overlooked because
people are like,
wow,
it's on scifinder battle's car,
battlestar Galactica,
but it was really well done.
Science fiction drama and then yeah,
Edward James almost was in it too.
And that woman that played starbuck.
What is her name?
Katie.
Katie sackhoff.
Yeah,
she was fucking great.
she was great.
There were,
there was a lot of great actors,
a lot of great,
interesting characters in there.
Um,
you know,
uh,
even characters that really made you not
like them.
Like,
um,
uh,
what's Nakita?
He's the guy,
the guy to the guy to the,
to the right next to her.
Uh,
the professor really hate him.
Um,
yeah,
you hit skies,
tar.
Yeah,
there was a lot of people that you hate
it,
but God damn was a good show.
Yeah,
it was great.
Yeah.
And a lot of these,
I don't see many of these people in
anything today.
I mean obviously,
uh,
James Edward almost as a famous actor,
but otherwise I don't,
I don't see them sprinkling anyone.
Not that I watch a lot of things.
Yeah,
I know man.
I always wonder about that.
When you see someone's in some gigantic
hit show and then they kind of vanish,
you know,
like where,
where did you go?
Yeah,
maybe,
maybe they wanted to go do something
else or maybe they can't get,
you know,
I would assume that they all could kind
of write their own their own way.
You think that.
But I think that also people get
pigeonholed into a character.
You know,
there's certain characters where you see
someone and they're on the Sopranos and
from then on there,
Christopher moltisanti forever.
I mean that's who he is,
right forever.
And it's hard to break out of that for a
lot of people.
The one person that managed to get out
of there was a um,
uh,
the,
the wife,
I can't think of her name.
Can you talk?
Go?
Yeah.
She was obviously big before that too in
some things,
but she didn't nurse Jackie and all
those kinds of things.
Some people get managed to break out of
that,
but you're right.
Did when you were on news radio and
stuff,
did you find when you,
when you went to,
to casting or anything like that?
I never really acted again.
So yeah,
I guess you found your way into fear,
fear factor and stuff like that so.
Well.
But you never even to do anything after
that.
I was offered some stuff that was
terrible.
Like there some sitcoms that just came
my way and you know,
you read the scripts and they were just
there.
The real problem was that news radio was
so good that the curse of being with
that talented cast and amazing writing
and amazing production and,
and also nobody knew about us.
Like when we were on the air,
like people that hear about news radio,
most of what people heard about was from
news radio's reruns.
Like when we went into syndication,
then we started playing.
That's when people start really getting
into news radio news radio really found
a big audience after it was canceled,
which is ironic.
Yeah,
it's unfortunate,
but it was good because the show didn't
have anybody fucking with it very much
like we didn't we.
It was a weird show in that regard.
It was not a hit like that show was not
a hit show.
While I was on the arrows.
My friend Lou Martin,
who is one of the writers,
he would wear a different t shirt.
He would come down to the table,
reads in a different t shirt with a
number on it based on what our rankings
was and the ratings,
and he came down once and it said,
number 88.
I go,
fuck dude,
we're number 88.
And he was like,
oh my God,
we're getting canceled.
And they start thinking,
fuck,
why did I get that lease in that
apartment?
I'm doomed now.
My sister Dana was a big fan of the
show.
I remember when it was on because I'm
the youngest by far of all my siblings
and um,
so she,
I think it,
I think it's a little surreal that I'm
on the show actually for her,
but I,
I,
yeah,
I think it's still on syndication.
I feel like I've seen it or maybe maybe
maybe like those deep channels maybe
like maybe I'm trying to think some
things.
What does that one down there or the
space one,
like see that's.
See the woman meet with a white jumpsuit
on Jamie.
See,
that's a perfect example of how fucking
weird they were.
They did these weird ones where we were
on.
That's not it.
That's not the same one.
That's not the space one.
We did one where we were in space for
some reason,
but it was the same.
Was the same fucking newsroom,
but the newsroom was taking place in
space.
They did a lot of weird shit.
They did one where we were completely
underwater.
Um,
we did like a titanic episode where we,
we literally filmed the show in waist
high water and we're on a ship and we
more like old school Lee close like from
people that,
you know,
from the titanic days,
it's just an extremely go to that
picture down there,
go back to that,
that scroll up,
scroll up with a picture of the cast
when I'm wearing sunglasses over there
were at some.
That's uh,
that was when we went to the,
um,
the emmy's after Phil was murdered.
And uh,
he still lost in the emmys and day for
parents to me right after they gave it
to the guy from frazier.
He goes,
what the fuck does he have to do to win?
Know,
it was such a hilarious moment where me
and me and Dave were just laughing to
each other.
It's just strange times,
man.
It's weird to go back and look at
yourself to from,
you know,
whatever it was 20 years ago.
It's a strange.
Would you ever,
do you have any interest in ever doing
something like this again or you never
know?
I have no desire.
It's a lot of work.
It's,
this is so easy.
I'm so fucking spoiled.
Come down,
sit down with people like you.
Have a nice conversation,
talk,
talk about interesting things that are
happening right now.
It's fun,
you know.
Um,
and not that,
that wasn't fun.
It was really fun,
but it's somebody else's thing and it's
a lot of work,
you know,
like it took a lot away from my standup.
It took a lot away from doing other
things.
You know,
when I started doing,
I started doing UFC commentary back then
too in [inaudible] 97 is when news radio
was on the air.
I was actually the interviewer,
the post-fight interviewer and um,
they would say they would treat me
literally like I was going off to do
porn.
They were like,
why are you doing this?
Like you're going to fly to Alabama to
work for a cage fighting organs and
you're a fucked up person.
And I was like,
this is the sport of the future.
I know you're crazy.
You saw something.
A lot of people didn't.
I think so.
Good.
I don't know why man.
Well,
honestly,
I probably didn't really see something.
I just saw what I liked and I,
for whatever reason,
good or bad,
there's me 19,
97 for whatever reason,
good or bad.
I've always a hundred percent trusted my
instincts.
Like I,
when I,
when I like something,
I go,
well,
I've got to go do that because it's what
I've always done.
So that's what's led me through my life.
Like if I went back and I've looked at
my,
my decision to get obsessed with martial
arts or my decision to quit all that and
get obsessed with standup comedy,
my decision for they made all the
decisions that I've made have all been
insanely impulsive,
passionate,
driven,
um,
derided by everyone around me.
Like,
what?
You're going to do,
But they ultimately,
it all worked well.
It's how your,
your story so interesting to me because
you have legitimately large pieces of
your audience that know you for totally
different things.
The guys that watch UFC and see you kind
of do,
you know,
in that sphere.
And then you have the guys that watch
the show and or listen to the show and
you have obviously people that love you
as a standup comic.
And then obviously the crossover between
all of those.
So you've managed to create,
you've managed to create like three
different viable lives that all
intermix.
It's pretty cool.
Well,
the UFC thing,
it's very strange because whether or not
anybody a agrees with my opinions on
life outside of it,
they know that when I'm doing commentary
I am doing my absolute best to honor
what's happening inside the octagon and
I have a deep knowledge and
understanding of what's going on.
Like this isn't like.
Do you remember when,
I don't know if you remember this,
but Dennis Miller used to do
Monday night football.
I do remember that.
Yeah.
People fucking hate.
Yeah,
it was,
it was.
Yeah,
I remember.
it was so mad.
There was so mad at him.
And this was before I think I was doing
fear fat or before I was doing,
um,
the UFC or maybe I was doing the post
fight interviews,
but I hadn't done the commentary yet
either one.
But I was like,
you can't force funny into something
where people want to watch the thing,
you know,
like you can't force funny into like
alien the movie alien,
right?
Like,
it's not supposed to be funny.
The thing is this is a dramatic,
horrifying science fiction movie.
You don't force funny into something
like that.
And that's what I felt like Dennis
Miller is like,
this is just like backwards sharp had,
you know,
he's like one liner,
one liner,
like that's his thing,
you know,
that's what he did.
But I never did that.
I always just did commentary.
Like if you heard me do commentary,
unless something happens,
it's fucked up in,
in,
inside the octagon and I have to go,
what the fuck is this?
And then I go on a rant about something.
People would have no idea that I was
funny at all.
Right,
well,
and that's the kind of nurturing those
different audiences.
Right.
And,
and,
but I wasn't,
I never thought about that way.
It's not like a concerted effort to
nurture anything.
It's just the UFC in specific is it's
about,
first of all,
it's about getting out of my own way and
honoring what's happening.
It's like you have to kind of honor.
You've got to think when a guy like
there's a big fight this weekend,
right?
Tj dillashaw is gonna fight.
Cody Garbrandt.
It's probably the biggest bantamweight
fight of all time.
When those two guys get into the
octagon,
you're dealing with the consequences of
the history of an entire division.
The probably the two best champions in
that division going at it.
The two of the three best champions,
dominick Cruz being the other one going
at it in this historical match up like
there's a lot.
You have a lot of responsibility and
they have to think about it that way.
It's not about you at all,
right?
No,
I think.
I think it's A.
I think it's,
it's,
it's interesting because I feel like
I've actually been challenged in that
same way.
You know,
because I came up as a gaming
commentator and Dennis Miller.
I think a lot of the reason people were
kind of concerned about him too is that
he would tell political jokes or bring
political things in,
which was unheard of at the time on
Monday night football around football
and the NFL generally,
and now it's part,
part and parcel with the NFL.
I'm a huge football fan,
so I'm,
I'm bearing witness to it every,
every week.
Um,
but I,
as a gaming commentator I've often found
some difficulty in keeping out shades of
that shades of politics and kind of
social commentary and what I did as well
and that all that's certainly alienated
some people,
but I also think it engendered.
I'm like,
wow,
this guy's honest and just tells you
exactly what he thinks as well.
So I was,
I was able to benefit from that,
but I also don't have the audience that,
that you have as well.
And I think keeping it structured and
separated,
this is wise,
you know what I mean?
It is sometimes,
but it's also sometimes wise to just be
yourself and that way you never have to
worry if people like you for who you
are.
If you pretend to be someone else,
like that's like,
okay,
I hate to bring
him up again,
but cosby is one of the grossest parts
about it.
We had it in our head that this guy was
this squeaky clean,
you know,
Middle America,
perfect example of this ethical,
moral guy.
Meanwhile I was a fucking rapist.
You know,
when you're around something like that,
you appreciate someone who's just
themselves,
you know,
I mean,
obviously you don't appreciate him if he
himself is a rapist.
Right.
That's maybe a bad example,
but,
but what,
like,
what do you define yourself as?
Do you think of yourself as a
libertarian?
Are you a Republican?
No,
I was a republican.
I left the party after trump won the
nomination.
You like enough?
Well,
because I can't,
I can't,
I couldn't stand them.
I consider myself a moderate republican
or a moderate conservative.
Don't you think it's interesting that
trump was a democrat his whole life?
Yes.
I think he's just an opportunist and,
and,
and I think the Republicans wanted to
just win.
Um,
but I also think he had 17 people in
that field or 16 other people in that
field and he was winning primaries and
caucuses with 35 percent of the vote.
So,
um,
and then he obviously I have no problem
with the electoral college,
but he didn't win the popular vote.
And so I,
I,
so to me I was like,
I identify as conservative.
I feel like the word libertarian has
been totally bastardized.
Like we were talking about words that
don't mean anything anymore where people
almost look at libertarianism is like
anarchy.
And,
and to me,
I'm like,
I'm a social libertarian.
I always call myself a social
libertarian.
I believe that drugs should be
decriminalized.
I think that,
um,
you know,
obviously this stage and be really
involved in litigating who isn't getting
married.
I think if you want to have a polygamous
relationship and everyone's cool with
that,
that's fine.
All of that kind of stuff.
A prostitution should be legal.
I think all of that is true.
But from a governmental standpoint,
I think that the government has a place,
um,
I think that the government can do
positive things that only the government
can do.
Um,
and so I,
I'm,
I'm also a protectionist and stuff.
So I also don't,
I also don't believe in a lot of
libertarian mantra.
A lot of people call me a libertarian,
but I,
I don't,
I haven't called myself that in a long
time.
What makes you lean towards
conservatism?
A conservatism to me is simply,
um,
uh,
the idea that government shouldn't be
involved where it doesn't need to be
involved if there is no justification
for it.
So,
so if someone
to you,
they wouldn't think conservative.
You've got an earring,
you got tattoos and a young guy.
You're not a hipster.
I wouldn't say a hipster,
but your millennial less.
Yeah,
I am.
It was funny,
I was listening to some guy talking
about me,
I want of his political shows and he's
like,
and he presents his hip and I'm like,
I know what number.
Yeah,
I present this hip anytime.
That's not a bad idea too.
But,
but the,
uh,
I was like,
I've never,
no one's ever called me hit before,
but yeah,
I didn't even a thing anymore.
Hipster,
hipster.
Yeah.
I don't want this.
Your hip,
I guess.
I mean,
I guess I don't,
I don't even really understand exactly
know a hipster when you see one,
but I still can't really tell you what
it,
what it means.
You can see some of them,
man,
for sure.
You see them coming.
Yeah.
But the big,
you know,
sometimes the big ads glasses and the
crazy out of a teaches on,
uh,
but I,
I consider myself a conservative simply.
I believe that the government is too
big.
Um,
I think that the government doesn't need
to be involved in everything that's
involved in.
Um,
and I think that the idea of
conservatism is simply inconsistent.
Um,
I think the conservative position on,
on the web,
a women's right to choose is pro choice.
I don't think it's prolife I think that
the conservative,
because it means that the government's
not telling you what to do,
just as if it just,
as the government doesn't have the right
to have confiscatory taxes,
just like the government doesn't have
the right to take your guns.
The government doesn't have the right to
tell you.
You can't marry a man if you're a man
and the government doesn't have a right
to tell you,
um,
you know,
all,
that you can't have an abortion.
So the true classic sense of
conservative ideals versus what we see
today where it's sort of a mixture of
conservative philosophy,
but the religious influence,
right?
There's a tremendous amount of religious
influence because,
well,
from the Reagan days,
right?
When,
when Reagan sort of courted the
religious,
right?
Yeah,
it actually started with like even even
Nixon and it's the southern strategy and
all those kinds of things.
And the idea that,
um,
that,
you know,
the map has changed like we in,
in American politics until really the
civil war parties were coming and going
constantly like that parties where,
you know,
the federalist in anti-federalists by
the Times James Madison had James Monroe
or president,
those are really antiquated terms.
Those were only five presidents in
between Madison and you know,
or Montereau and Washington.
So,
you know,
we had this churn,
the know nothings free soil,
all these kinds of things.
And suddenly the Democrats come out
during antebellum America.
Republicanism begins in 18,
56 and you have this idea of these
parties that just exists still to this
day and simply morph constantly into
these different things.
Making me wonder why we don't just have
new parties constantly.
But to your point,
the reason that conservatism and
liberalism aren't,
these aren't in these neat buckets
anymore is because they're tied to these
parties and they have to constantly
justify themselves.
The Republicans under ulysses s grant
and Teddy Roosevelt were the original
progressives.
They were the ones that wanted land to
be set aside for national parks.
They were the ones that freed obviously
the slaves,
you know,
not so much Teddy Roosevelt as much as
the ulysses s grant and all of these
kinds of things and suddenly everything
changes and then suddenly everything
changes again and so on and so forth.
And so none of these words have any
definitions anymore,
which is why I didn't identify with
republicanism anymore because I was
like,
I consider myself a moderate
conservative.
But what's conservative about
evangelicalism,
what's conservative,
um,
about,
uh,
even even ideas like free trade and
stuff like that,
like the idea of just having these,
these open markets that destroy your,
your ability to manufacture things that
drive wages down,
that do all these kinds of things.
Nothing conservative about that at all,
you know?
And,
and so to me I was like,
I just had to find my own way forward.
So I just consider myself independent,
you know?
And,
and,
and I feel like I'm consistent in what I
say because I think you can match them
all up and I don't think there's any
consistency in saying you can't marry
this man.
Uh,
but don't take my gun.
You can't have this polygamous
relationship,
um,
you know,
but uh,
we should have prayer in school.
It's like,
it doesn't,
these things will make sense to me,
you know,
like the,
you have to be consistent.
Well,
the religious things always seemed to me
to be compromised as to get the support
of the religious right.
It seems like they moved towards those
directions because it sort of reinforces
the power that they have behind them
because they're the only candidates that
are willing to do that.
Right.
Whereas the left is not willing to.
They're,
they're not willing to go down that
religious road in the sense of a woman's
right to choose and the sense of a lot
of things that they get liberals to
support them.
It would be antithetical.
They would lose that support.
But do you think that a guy like having
a guy like trump in office that one of
the good things about having a guy
that's obviously fairly unhinged and
ridiculous is that we need to reconsider
like what it is to be a president and
this idea that this guy could get into
this position by just sort of calling
everybody and doing a lot of make
America great again speeches and saying
a lot of crazy shit about we're going to
build that wall 10 feet higher and all
that.
The other nutty rhetoric that went on
during the campaign and then seeing him
in office and seeing who knows if he's
going to get out of these four years
without going to jail.
Right.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I,
I,
I think that there is,
I think you can glean positive and
obviously negative things out of trump's
administration so far.
Right?
What do you glean positive?
I think what's positive is what we were
talking about earlier,
that the system works that like nothing
has broken,
broken down at all.
In fact,
like we've seen from the circuit courts
all the way to the Supreme Court and
with Congress that there actually are,
these are legitimately viable and
independent bodies and the and the
checks and balance system.
Right?
And this is why I think it's so deeply
offensive to,
to,
you know,
in a way it'd be like,
well,
fascism alive in America and,
and I'm like,
it's not,
it's not what fascism would've looked
like from a governmental standpoint is
trump's coming in,
suspending the supreme court dismissing
Congress and trying all these crazy
things that would have happened.
And that's what fascism looks like.
What fascism does it look like?
Is you passing a travel ban and the
supreme court saying no,
and then you're trying to pass it again.
And then the circuit courts say,
no,
you know,
and that's not what fascism,
that's what republicanism,
small r republicanism looks like.
And so I think we can glean positive
things out of this that people got mad
at me after the election because I was
like,
the world's not ending.
I actually tweeted it that night.
People were losing their minds.
I'm like,
it's gonna,
be fine.
People are super emotional.
They were,
but understand what we've survived.
We understand when we've had elections,
like what has happened,
right?
We had an election in 18,
60,
and really,
and even in 18,
56 and 1952 when things started to
really start to fall apart and we had
one in 18,
64 during the civil war,
we had an election in 1932 during the
depression.
We had an election in 1944 when we were
fighting the Nazis and the Japanese at
the same time.
We can survive this way.
We didn't.
No one came in and said like,
we don't need an election now or on
toward.
Things were happening.
We still went through the rigors of our
system every four years.
Everything stood up.
Everything was fine and that the
suggestion that Donald Trump is going to
be the guy that the,
the confederates didn't do it,
the Nazis didn't do it.
The Japanese didn't do it.
Nothing to Donald Trump's going to be
the one that destroys the American
republic.
It's absurd.
And so I and I,
I take,
I take that as a positive,
but what I take is a negative is it?
We're just wasting time.
It's just time wasted.
It's good theater.
It's entertaining,
but it's not funny because nothing,
they've not gotten anything done.
And I want tax cuts.
I think that's great.
I,
I want some reasonable things happening
that the congress can pass with trump
the sign,
but I think these are just wasted four
years,
you know?
And so that's not funny at all.
It's just,
it's,
it's making the problems worse.
Lot of wheel spinning.
Exactly.
We have deep problems,
$20,000,000,000,000
in debt,
a massive deficit.
Uh,
we're spending $600,
billion on our military,
$600,000,000,000
on our military.
It's nuts.
It's insane.
We have to start asking ourselves
questions of geopolitics.
Do we need to be in Japan anymore?
Do we need to have these bases and
Poland?
Do we need to,
you know,
we have a lot of weight,
but we,
we can't get past this buffoon that's
our president in order to start asking
ourselves the questions.
So we just have to punt until a normal
person's in there again and I think
we'll get a normal pr.
I think he'll survive his turn,
but I think,
I don't think he'll run again.
I'm,
I'm of the mind that he won't run again.
Specifically specifically already ran
for reelection.
He's already filed.
Well he,
yeah,
he's filing it.
He's raising money.
But I specific,
I think that one's Kellyanne Conway and
these other people that are engineered
the election for them to begin with
after the midterms,
which I think are going to be
interesting.
I think the midterms actually benefit in
some ways the Republicans because of the
map in the Senate.
But I think that when it becomes clear
that he can not.
When you were thinking you were going
again?
I,
I don't.
So it's interesting because I'm friends
with.
I'm good friends.
I went to college with this girl who's a
lobbyist in Washington.
She is a Democrat and she's pretty well
connected and I had dinner with her a
couple weeks ago and she was like,
not only will trump running and he'll
win and,
and this was when everything was going
on and all this and I'm like,
I just don't see him subjecting himself
to the possibility of losing.
He won once,
you know,
and it reminds me of 2004 when Bush won
again,
but he also won the popular vote,
you know,
he'd be carry and it kinda legitimize
himself.
I think that trump is gonna risk further
illegitimized himself by subjecting
himself to,
you know,
not only a primary which is going to
happen,
which is the death knell for an
incumbent.
Think Gerald,
Gerald Ford,
Jimmy Carter,
how that went for them when they were
primary because they were so unpopular.
And then he goes in and there's going to
be the dumb.
If the Democrats are smart,
they put someone up that's really good.
Um,
and uh,
but,
and I also think there's gonna be an
independent candidate that's gonna screw
everything up as well.
So I think he has a very,
very high likelihood of running again
and I think he could absolutely could
win again.
Do you think you'll win the primary?
Because I'm not even sure he would get
through the primary.
I don't know.
I mean it all depends on what happens
over the next three years.
Obviously I'm in no way shape or form a
political expert,
but I think that we got a lot of dummies
in this country and all we need is
momentum.
All you need is one event,
some big thing to happen where Donald
Trump solves a problem.
Do you remember how happy people were
with George Bush directly after World
War war?
More war after September 11th,
after September 11th and he made a bunch
of speeches and set a bunch of things
and his approval rating shot 90 percent
or something like that shot up and
people were very excited and they were
like,
this is.
This
is the reason why we need sort of a good
old boy president,
just because when push comes to shove,
they know how to get the men in uniform
behind it and just take care of this
problem with military might and make
America great again and all that kind of
horseshit.
If something like that happens with
trump and trump,
you remember he had that one speech.
Jamie can give me another one of these
things.
Please let me handle that one speech
where I'm everybody's like,
oh,
that was.
That was presidential.
Like he had won presidential speech.
He spoke in front of Congress and
everyone was clapping and he said a
bunch of things like all you need.
All he needs is one event,
something that happens where he steps up
and manages it with a reasonable
vocabulary and and does things that
people approve of especially some sort
of a catastrophic situation or any sort
of a military situation.
If we have to deal with North Korea,
if we have to deal with something where
there's a real legitimate concerns,
thanks pat.
If that happens and he manages it,
people get scared and they don't want
change.
I think if that happens,
it's entirely likely if we have to deal
with some sort of a catastrophe,
some sort of a tragedy,
some sort of an attack or an event,
and Donald trump manages it well,
it's entirely likely that he could be
president.
Sure.
There could be a.
There could be a moment like that.
I wouldn't throw.
I mean I went through anything past him
specifically because I and many other
people were so wrong about his ability
to win to begin with.
I thought I just didn't.
I thought he would do,
but I kept saying he's going to do
better and get more votes than people
thought,
but I didn't think he had a prayer of
winning,
but there are certain things you can
look at where it's like,
well,
it's.
It's about 50,000
votes along three states that he even
wanted all the vote was suppressed
priest and I'm not saying he was at.
It was actively suppress.
People just weren't enthusiastic about
this,
so people weren't out there to vote.
Now people see the consequences of not
voting.
Um,
I don't think that.
I don't think that it's like the.
I guess what I'm saying is that the
prognostication that like this is the
end of the world,
right?
Like that Donald trump being president,
that we've had terrible presence,
you know,
like we've had really bad presidents.
He's the worst.
Yeah,
in some sense he's,
I'll say that he's the most incompetent.
We've had some.
We've had some presidents that were just
in shitty situations that they couldn't
manage long time ago.
Yeah,
I would say hoover's probably the last
one.
And then Puke James Buchanan.
Obviously it's an awful precedent.
The in,
in 18,
57,
the state starts to secede when he was
president,
so,
and he couldn't do anything about it.
Um,
so we've had to really die or serious
situations under presidents that were
not,
that were in over their heads,
but there also is no footage of them.
There's no film.
You have to really go back and read
history to understand the
sequences of their actions where we're
seeing all this play out in real time.
We're seeing the poverty of his
vocabulary,
the way he communicates in the press,
the way he pats himself on the back.
Like the other day,
he said he has one of the great memories
of all time and like he says,
things that are just preposterous.
The one about him being an Ivy Lee.
I went to an Ivy League school.
I'm an intelligent mind.
I don't.
I'm one of the guys that says like,
I don't think he's dumb at all.
I don't.
I don't think he's stupid.
I just think
in over his head.
I don't ever see him in the nineties.
Talk about running for president.
You ever see that video footage?
I think it was on Charlie rose or
something like that.
Starting an 88.
He started talking about it either.
Yeah,
all the way there.
And when you go back and listen to that,
like first of all did something happen
to his brain.
Like why is he so clunky now?
Like wire his sentence is so poorly
formed and speech pattern.
So shitty.
Now maybe that's what you gotta wonder
about.
Like old dudes.
They get to a certain age.
Especially guys like him who don't
exercise,
don't eat well,
yes,
KFC bucket and it's got a big fat gut
and just like how well or is neurons
firing,
you know,
he's,
he's see if we can find that video of
him back from you.
Got It.
Like,
watch this,
listen to this.
I think that if you had to do it again,
I'm not sure you could.
I went through a period of two years
that was truly tough.
Well,
you know,
you have parents and you have people
that adore you and you have people that
for 15 years nothing went wrong and then
all of a sudden the world seems to be
coming to an end.
I mean it just seems to become.
And it's just a,
it was just sort of an incredible
experience for me.
This is him.
Good,
humbled.
Talking about going bankrupt.
I'd like to hear him talking about
running for president.
My father wouldn't have been in mission
to bail me out,
but he certainly helped and you know,
morally and as the whole interview with
my mother was great.
I have a sister,
she's very just listen to listen to a
speech pattern,
never knew as to loyalty whether or not
should be there or wouldn't be there and
she was there in spades,
other people with them.
But you know,
the,
the incredible thing is you can't really
tell.
You can't really tell who's going to be
there,
who's not.
Um,
I would have bet my life on certain
people.
I would have said a politically speaking
that somebody that,
you know,
Andrew Stein would have been there and
it wasn't.
I would have said that other people,
what he wasn't there in terms of for 15
years I supported Andrew Stein,
supported them.
I never asked him for a thing when I
needed a vote.
One Riverside South until the very end
when everybody else was on board.
Andrew was not there and I was,
I was really surprised at that.
Now ultimately he was there,
but it shouldn't have been so difficult.
It really shouldn't have been.
Here comes,
one of the things they say about you is
that their ticks within you,
a vindictiveness about that and you're
not gonna forget that.
And part of the trump style,
at some point you're going to try to get
Stein back.
Well,
I don't think I'm going to try and get
stuff back.
I'm just disappointed.
I'm disappointed in other people and I'm
not disappointed in some the.
Okay.
Then people point is he seems like a
much more reasonable person cogent like,
yeah,
maybe he's going to maybe see a little.
See now I have no idea.
Also,
I think,
and this is something I've been really,
I'm battling,
not battling but bouncing around in my
head a lot lately,
is that I think this,
this hate of him,
the,
the constant insults,
the attacks on him,
the constant.
I mean he blogs people on twitter all
the time because people.
And now people are suing him to say that
he can't block them on twitter anymore.
We're being very petulant about that
stuff.
But this,
all of this like the center live satires
of um,
all the,
all the shit that they do is ramping up
his mania.
And it's,
it's actually bad for all of us,
you know,
and that you don't get someone to change
by going,
hey,
fucking change.
You know,
you're a piece of shit.
Like that doesn't make people change.
It makes people aware that you hate them
and it depending entirely upon their
personality,
whether or not they're reflective or
introspective,
how they,
how they react to that.
He seems to react to it by,
by like doubling down and by getting
more aggressively defensive and more
self aggrandizing and more self
congratulatory,
you know,
he seems to get more trump.
Yeah.
You know,
it's almost like he's the hulk like you
ever received.
When they shoot,
the hockey gets bigger.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
He definitely,
he doesn't deal with.
He's in a situation where someone needs
to lower their rifles.
Right.
And point.
And after he was elected,
I thought for sure that smart people are
in his,
in his transition team and he's not
surrounded by dumb people.
He surrounded by inexperienced political
operatives,
but he's not surrounded by dumb people
that someone at some point what it said
like we can now get down to the act of
governing and I'm of the mind that if he
just started acting more normal,
if you stopped tweeting so much,
if he just spoke at a more normal in a
more normal way,
did normal things.
People would have forgotten a lot of
what happened during the campaign and he
would have been in much better shape to
get legislative goals through and stuff
like that.
But he,
he can't help himself.
Like he,
he,
and that's why I think like this
destructive.
I don't,
I just don't know that the American
people are going to want this again.
Like I think that I think that he has a
base of 30,
35 percent that will be there,
but isn't that what Obama had?
It is lowest for approval ratings.
Yeah.
And the second term I think he was down
down to that
I can think is lowest approval ratings
were,
were higher than trump's lowest,
but he's in the neighborhood.
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm not even saying [inaudible] approval
ratings are fickle.
You can do all sorts of shifts to
manipulate those numbers and,
and trump would,
you know,
interestingly and rightfully maybe say
like,
look at the economy,
it's doing great.
Look at the stock market.
It's doing great.
I think we're economy was on the sort of
deceptive,
right?
Because the economy was on an upward
trend,
right?
And again,
it's caught
that wave right there is a real belief
by business people that Donald trump is
going to make things easier for them
because of his nature.
The Fuck Jamie,
what happened?
Motherfuckers with their ads,
um,
that we,
we have this sense that the business
people think that he's going to
alleviate restrictions.
He's going to make things easier because
you had to open up doors and he's going
to do that.
Some people would think are very
unpopular.
Like one of the things he's done is he
made it so you can bring back lion
trophies now again from Africa.
So if people want to go to Africa and
shoot lions,
you could bring them over,
which is bizarre.
It doesn't make any what?
What is a digital?
No other president.
What does this.
Trump's approval rating is bad day one
97 of his presidency,
5:30
pegged.
That is 37 percent.
No other president in history of modern
polling had an approval rate.
So dismal on day one.
One 97.
According to 5:38
tracker,
a former president Gerald Ford came
close to matching trump,
but could a have boasted and approval
rate of nearly two point five percent
points higher.
It wouldn't be super surprised.
And Have Obama Fall into that high
thirties,
low forties and his second term because
that's when they don't care anymore.
Yeah.
Um,
and that's when they really start to
take initiative and do certain things.
So I was approved.
I didn't see it below like 47 percent.
Obama.
Yeah.
He must have been a with.
Oh,
is this,
this approval is a little different than
a approval or disapproval.
That's true,
yeah.
Okay.
There's a disapproval rating.
Disapprove,
or do you approve it?
You can be neutral on that.
Right.
So if like there's a disapproval rating
of 50 percent,
it doesn't mean is that approval rating
of fifth year?
Correct.
Right.
Okay.
I think,
you know,
it's funny because I think with,
with there are certain things that I
think people don't understand that are
unpopular,
that do need to be done specifically for
businesses.
I own a business,
I've owned two of them.
You have run your own business,
it seems like with all of your
adventures as well and it's very hard
and,
and a lot of people look at,
I'm just from an administrative
paperwork standpoint,
taxes,
all those kinds of things.
It's,
it's awful.
And I think a lot of people pointed
business big and small and they look at
them as like these ways you can kind of
like get blood out of a stone and take
it and extract as much money out of them
as possible and all these kinds of
things.
A lot of people are not sympathetic to
it because no offense,
they have no idea what they're talking
about.
And I've been watching the west wing
again,
which I love.
I love that show.
I never watched it.
Oh,
it's fantastic.
You probably love it.
You should,
you should check it out.
So it's just a great show.
And one of the things they say in there
is that the major difference we are,
people call us a democracy,
but we're not a democracy.
We're a public and the idea is that you
send,
you vote for people that go make
decisions on your behalf and sometimes
those decisions are going to be
unpopular,
but some people do know better than
others.
And so there are certain things,
I don't necessarily judge a move based
only on popularity because what does,
what does society at large know about
running a business?
Nothing.
So you have to ask people that
understand what it is to run a business
and how you can make that easier.
So we can't judge things based on that.
Only my major concern with him though is
that he's so unpopular even in his own
party and even specifically with the
House that because they are constantly
up for reelection that you know,
it,
they haven't had one legislative like
when uh,
in,
in the entire time he's been president
does not have all the positions fully
staffed as well.
Yeah.
There,
there are things and that's not uncommon
either that sometimes things go for
years without being staffed or whatever.
I think part of the problem is so crazy.
Like how the fuck do you take office
without all the pieces in place because
they,
I who knows the conspiracy theories run
deep on this one,
but I don't think he thought he was
going to win and I'm not even sure he
wanted to win.
And I,
and,
and I don't think that they had a real
transition like a.
I Read Hillary Clinton's book,
what happened,
which is an interesting book.
You read the whole thing?
Yep.
You okay?
Yeah,
I'm okay.
What is this?
What happened?
Because I'd be interested in high part
of the time.
Yeah.
Out laying in the bed,
in the bathtub reading.
Um,
but uh,
as I said the you'd have to be high to
read but I wanted to perspective,
right?
Like I think it's interesting and,
and well there's a lot of things in
there but one of the things she was
talking about was that she had,
they were fully prepared for their
transition.
So you're,
you're dealing,
which is not surprised.
She was actually talking about in
October she started taking regular
meetings because they assumed that she
was gonna win about how she was going to
stack things and the decisions they were
going to make in the first 100 days.
And I think you just have something
that's like over the top bravado.
Right.
And on the other end,
ironically for someone with so much
bravado,
you have someone that just was totally
not prepared to win because I don't
think anyone inside except for maybe
Kellyanne Conway was telling think
that's the case.
Or do you think it was just
concentrating entirely on winning and
then figure it out once it gets in
there?
Maybe,
but you're,
you should.
I mean,
it could be anything we,
the definitive book on this has not been
written yet unfortunately.
And actually mark Halperin who was
writing that book and now he's,
he's finished with that.
You realized that he has such a limited
understanding of what even his powers
are and what you like.
What was the guy he spoke to?
We said I had a conversation with the
president of the US Virgin Islands.
Like,
Hey,
you're the president of the US Virgin
Islands.
Yeah,
he makes,
he makes them stupid.
He makes some stupid mistakes.
He,
he doesn't.
I mean I remember.
Yeah,
that was there some moments like that
where I'm like,
you're funny,
but,
but unfortunately the situation doesn't
call for being funny,
but it's not,
it's not humorous humorous situation.
And I feel like specifically with,
um,
in terms of governance,
I think he just like,
I remember the debates where he didn't
know what the nuclear triad was,
which is like the fuck.
You not know what the nuclear triad is
and where he speaking around issues that
are,
are somewhat basic,
right?
That someone that's running for
president,
you know,
and when you multiply that by not being
a candidate,
but by being the man in the office and
then being inundated by the realities of
the office,
he was just ill prepared for it and he,
part of the reason he wanted because he
was an outsider and part of being an
outsider is alienating everyone around
you.
That is an insider.
So he has no one,
very few people that are willing to work
for him that are capable.
Which is why I think that,
um,
you know,
there's this idea,
I don't know if you've read about it,
there's this idea that there's basically
a soft coup going on in the American
government right now.
Have you talked about,
have you heard about this at all?
That general Maddis who's secretary of
defense and then General Kelly who is
the chief of staff,
are basically running things and that
we.
And it's kind of a scary idea because
military coups,
or even if they're soft,
they're not constitutional,
but that people take kind of solace in
this because they're like,
well,
people that are men of honor are kind of
making sure nothing crazy happens.
And I'm like,
well,
again,
this is such a waste of time.
We want something soft.
Cool.
Or is that just he
has given over the reins to the military
for the first time ever because most of
the time the president is in charge and
the military has to come to the
president for direction and for guidance
and for approval.
Whereas Donald Trump has kind of said,
look,
you people know what to do better than
anybody.
Do what you gotta do.
It could be that.
I mean,
yeah,
it could be voluntary,
but it's still its own sort of cool
because that's not what you're supposed
to do.
It's not what you're supposed to do.
Now I trust the military,
the American.
I'm better than him.
That's absolutely loves.
I was going to say was that typically a
military coup in history is a super
negative connotation than rejections.
Libyans,
whatever the case might be,
it always turns out bad,
but we have a honor,
like an honor driven military,
I think in the United States above all
others that will take care of things and
handed over if necessary,
but,
but the interesting thing that people
have been writing and talking about is
like what happens if he does?
If you want something crazy done and
they just don't do it.
We've never.
We've never had a situation like that.
Like what if,
what if you know what,
what,
what's going on in,
on the Korean Peninsula,
for instance,
very dangerous situation,
very dangerous situation.
What if he goes to escalate and they're
like,
we're not doing that.
Right.
That's actually the first time that we
know in recorded history where,
where the military is not responding to
the,
to the civilian government.
So there's,
it opens all these hypothetical
interesting things to think about.
Things that we haven't come to that
haven't come to pass yet.
Yeah.
I mean,
he hasn't requested anything completely
bizarre yet,
but he said some completely bizarre shit
about,
you know,
he needs essentially violated the United
Nations code or how you communicate with
other governments.
Right.
I mean he said he threatened them.
What was the,
what?
The terrible,
horrible things.
Fire and fury.
Fire and fury,
which is funny.
It's,
it's a,
it's A.
Well,
a lot of people didn't glean out of that
was that he was clearly watching truman,
Harry Truman videos.
Harry Truman said this pretty much the
same thing before he dropped a nuclear
bomb on Japan and there's videos of it
where he was like a rain of fury,
the likes of which the world has never
seen or something like that.
He says,
and I'm like,
well,
what?
You've been someone who's been tripping
truman quotes in the area because this
sounds awfully familiar to me.
It wasn't watching TV,
but uh,
to me it's like we,
it's especially precarious because yes,
a nuclear armed North Korea is not
ideal,
but there's no.
If you read any foreign policy papers or
any,
anything other think tanks,
there's no good solution out of this and
for him to be so flippant about it when
you're actually assured destruction is
the one policy that's kept everyone safe
for a very long time.
The idea that we will destroy you if you
do anything else and for strike
capabilities and all that kind of stuff.
The fact that he's playing with that
balance has major geopolitical
consequences in Asia,
which in turn can bring the Russians and
obviously the Chinese situation,
comic book sensibility to it that you
know,
you go and drop some nukes on North
Korea and everything saw problem solved.
That's no,
you just started a gigantic chain of
events that could lead to a bomb of
blowing off in a major American city or
more.
Yeah,
I mean at the very least you're talking
even if you.
Even if you disabled North Korea's
nuclear capabilities,
we don't really understand how their
icbm is work.
I was reading something today where they
actually had a major collapse of their
nuclear site of 200 people dead,
like tunnels,
collapse and stuff like that.
Like they're actually blowing up so many
bombs that they're actually weakening
their own structures and stuff like
that.
Um,
you have this situation where at the
very least,
even if you disabled everything and they
couldn't retaliate,
retaliate,
soul is 35 miles away from the border.
You're going to talk about tens of
thousands of people probably dead in a
few minutes.
And then you're getting us involved in.
There's a refugee crisis on the
northwest border of North Korea that's
funneling in the China.
China gets involved.
Russia also shares borders and has
insurance interests in,
in Asia and East Asia.
This isn't something that a man who
doesn't understand things needs to be
trifling with,
you know,
and uh,
it's,
you know,
I would love nothing more than to have
North Korea taken down a peg.
Like,
yeah,
but think he communicates with the
military.
I mean,
first of all,
how does he have the time to do
everything he's doing because he
doesn't.
I mean,
I'll answer it
before I even asked her.
He does.
No,
no human has the time to be the
president.
It's one of the problems with being
I mean what you were talking about
earlier,
how you have businesses and you run
things and how complicated and difficult
it is and those things are not.
No nothing compared to being the
president of thing and he's got to deal
with the economic situation.
He's got to deal with the military.
He's got to deal with immigration.
He's trying to build a fucking wall to
Mexico.
He's trying to bring jobs back to
America and he's playing golf 150 times.
Oh,
he's played golf 72 times.
Cost the taxpayer.
Seventy 6 million,
236,000,
$13 at least.
What is this website?
Trump golf count God.
Seventy two visits to golf clubs since
inauguration,
which confirmed golfing on at least 33
visits.
God Damn car frequently asked questions
for answers to frequently asked
questions and our complete data table
for the list of trump's outings.
He's hilarious.
No,
it's.
I mean,
it's the most complicated and all
encompassing jobs imaginable and he's
out golfing.
Yeah,
he's,
I mean,
once you got to have rest and
relaxation,
I don't begrudge you that,
but I wonder like again,
because of the alienation that went on
through the primaries and into the
campaign,
when you have people that are simply not
willing to work for you,
that are very capable.
Um,
what do you do?
I don't know.
I think that's why nothing's happening.
That's why when they had the healthcare
thing,
you know,
kind of crop up at early in the,
in the administration,
they weren't prepared.
When they don't have it,
they still have not really released all
the details of their tax plan.
It's like,
what are you guys like?
Nothing has really happened.
It's just that I'm telling you,
Joe,
that's the major thing that's a bummer
to me is it's just wasted time.
It's just wasted time.
We do not have time and again,
I don't think anybody has enough time to
actually be the president,
but I wonder like what conversations
he's having with the military and what,
how those decisions get made.
I don't really understand the process
enough to know,
like say if North Korea does something
stupid,
what,
what are the decisions and who,
who brings those decisions to the
president who brings us suggestions,
who lays out the possibilities and how
does that go?
So I think from what I understand,
the way it works is that there's a
situation room in the White House that
joint chiefs of Staff and the national
security advisor meet there to discuss
things.
A president comes in when they're ready
to,
to present them with things.
They present him based on the branch
that's dealing with it,
what's happening and then they give him,
you know,
what are reasonable responses or you
know,
wait and see kind of things or whatever.
And I think that's how it goes down.
And then he tells,
you know,
the joint chiefs to,
to act on his,
on his direction.
That's a great name for a room to the
situation room with Wolf Blitzer.
Your Situation Room?
Yeah.
How has he called him his own show?
That situation?
I don't know.
He got away.
He's getting away with it.
The fucking rude.
I know he's getting away with a wolf.
Blitzer is an interesting character and
a lot of these guys on cable news or are
interesting people to me,
especially now so.
Well,
because they're the,
the,
there's always been partisans.
We were talking about William F Buckley
and corporate al before.
Right.
But there's no pretenses now about
anything like,
like no matter who you're watching,
I don't,
I couldn't even tell you what a person
who doesn't have an ideal and open
ideological bent anymore and had had
some sort of,
um,
it's kind of like a means to an end for
them to get their information out there
the way they want it.
There's no like Walter cronkite's
anymore.
No completely objective journalist,
which I would love.
I would love that,
but I don't try.
I don't really.
That's why I don't really trust anything
the media says anymore.
It's not only trump,
it's just like there's always an agenda.
Yeah.
There's no one who's delivering it all
with a straight face.
Everyone has an editorial bent to it and
that's fine,
but I wish that it when the only place
that you can really go to get straight
up news now or the wires,
it's kind of like a little lonely,
you know,
go to ap and Reuters and then that's
pretty much it.
What about the Internet?
Is Anybody doing a good job of
disseminating objective news on the
Internet?
I don't think so.
Not that anyone that I've seen,
I think there's an opening for that.
If someone could figure it out.
There is,
but I don't.
The thing is,
is that the sad thing is I don't know if
there's even an audience for it,
you know,
like I think that people like you and I
that might want a more objective stance
to make up your own.
You know,
I remember I used to watch BBC World
News on pbs in college because it was
like this very outsider kind of like,
you know,
40,000
foot view of what was going on and I
feel like we don't even really have that
anymore and I feel like there's the
reason that those people don't exist is
because there is no,
there's no money there.
Yeah.
It seems like the big monies in
preaching to the choir.
Absolutely.
And that's,
that's why with what I was trying to do
is like,
uh,
I get,
I take a lot of honor that I get fired
from every angle,
which means that I'm doing something
right.
It's not like only the left wing people
that don't like me.
It's not only the people that don't like
me,
it's like everybody has some problem
with me,
which makes me feel like maybe I'm
somewhere in the middle,
but I haven't,
I haven't,
I don't have.
I don't know if I have an agenda.
I guess I do,
but I have a point of view.
The news to me is the most fascinating,
well the news networks because CNN seems
almost like it's just,
they're weighted down by rules and
restrictions in a certain sense where
it's Fox News.
He got Hannity who's just fucking
completely unhinged.
You had bill o'reilly.
He's trying to fuck everything that
moves.
I mean,
didn't that guy have like nine different
sexual harassment lawsuits that he
settled?
One of them for 35,
$35,000,000.
What the fuck did he do?
I can't imagine how much money he really
has from his books and stuff.
If he can even fork that much money over
because I was him.
Right.
That was even Fox.
I don't think.
I don't even think it was highly files.
$5,
million dollar defamation.
Suit over harassment claims.
Trying to get back.
Go back to that.
Let me read the text underneath it
please.
Former Fox News host,
Bill O'reilly on Friday,
filed a defamation suit against former
New Jersey state legislator,
Michael Panter.
Following a facebook post on Tuesday in
which panter detailed,
alleged sexual harassment by O'reilly
against an unnamed ex partner of
panthers.
Huh?
Wow.
Painters claims based on the
conversations with his ex and incidents
he said that he witnessed.
We're chilling.
Panter says that his then girlfriend's
enclosed career was largely dependent on
staying on a Riley's good graces,
uh,
and that'll riley repeatedly asked her
out and made sexually charged late night
phone calls to her.
That's his move.
He calls you up and says fucked up shit
on the phone.
What a freak.
It's crazy,
man.
He must've been like,
sort of the Harvey Weinstein sort of
thing.
Like he must have been doing that
forever.
That was his thing.
He would call chicks up.
Yeah.
What are you wearing?
I was about to call Reagan.
Got Him on speed dial.
It's from watching me jerk off.
It's,
it's,
it's totally bizarre.
Like the power of money.
It gives you some sort of presumed Valle
against.
Thinks he does,
but it's also the Fox News thing.
It's so sexually charged,
like I have a whole bit about the way
the men and the women dress on Fox News
because those women dress like they're
going out on a hot date and they're
talking about like important issues.
Right?
Yeah.
That little dresses and there always
seem to be sitting at the edges of the
table so you can see their legs,
right?
Yeah.
It was always very transparent to me.
I my,
my,
my thought was always like,
well,
these are old conservative men that are
watching this,
and you grabbed them.
Any way you can boil newt Gingrich's
feeling it.
Just holding onto a 70 year old.
Would our wish I had enough power to
stick it in any of these gals?
Do you think Newt Gingrich gets some hot
tail?
He's got probably did fairly well.
He wasn't,
he wasn't.
He wasn't a hill above and underwear.
A known philanderer.
A little of this little.
That sexiest ladies of Fox News as it
is.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Well,
it's interesting too that somebody
needed to talk to Megan Kelly.
Like,
what the fuck was she thinking?
Jumping ship and going over to NBC.
She's dying over there apparently.
Well,
of course she's dying.
You the Ice Queen.
You're supposed to be shouting down.
The liberals mock and everybody and
telling everybody that Santa Claus is
white.
That's your.
That's your thing.
Yeah.
She.
She's apparently like,
I keep reading about her,
about how people won't book on her show.
No,
well she's.
And she's bringing everyone down.
She's not stupid,
but she's pressured and when people are
under pressure they falter.
Especially people are not used to kind
of pressure
like she's used to people liking her.
Well,
I always thought she was brilliant on
Fox,
like the way she would communicate with
people.
She's very sharp,
but she just seemed so uncomfortable and
under pressure and nervous and awkward.
Like did you see the thing with will and
grace?
Oh yeah.
Where they had that exchange with
messing with a guy if he became gay
because he liked the character.
That was like what?
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
She had some other awkward.
Who was there was,
there was a couple early on where there
was a pretty awkward like exchanges
between her Jane Fonda,
Jane Fonda.
That's right.
That's what it was.
She asked about getting plastic surgery
and Jane Fonda just said,
are we really going to go there?
And then she went and I like to talk
about this movie.
This is what I like about this movie.
She'd basically just steam rolled her.
I,
I feel we were talking about typecasting
before,
right?
About how people didn't feel like she's
just,
she can't get away from what she was
also like,
that's a clunky,
stupid thing to do to try to talk about
plastic surgery when someone's promoting
a movie.
Sure.
She's just trying to get soundbites.
She's like,
he's calculated effort to get sound
bites of the people will put up youtube
clips.
Do you,
do you give a lot of interviews or ever
given interviews like a.
or have you ever had a bad experiences
with that?
Talking to me.
I'm saying you being the on your own
show anymore,
man.
I don't do them.
I feel like that's an incredibly
ineffective way to communicate.
I feel like you're doing yourself a
massive disservice to talk for five
minutes to someone that you don't even
know.
I mean,
if I wanted to talk to somebody,
I want to talk to them for hours and
let's do it live so that you can't edit
it.
You know?
I think that,
uh,
if you really want to communicate ideas,
that's not the way to do it is the way
to jump off a little sound clips and
sound bites and then we'll be right
back.
You know,
and you go to commercial and it's like,
well,
what are we living in the fifties?
Why?
Well,
this is a stupid way to do.
You guys need to revamp your whole
system.
The system sucks.
This is a shitty way to communicate with
people.
Why are we even talking like this?
You're sitting over there,
I'm sitting over here and we're looking
at each other sideways.
How come you're at a desk and I'm on a
couch.
Why do you have a desk where you write
in books?
Fuck,
are you doing over there in that desk?
This is the whole thing is just,
it's Jack Paar.
It's Johnny Carson.
It's just like this old school dumb way
of conducting these interviews.
What?
You have a band here?
Well,
let's let the band play us out.
It's like capital s show.
It's fucking dumb.
I don't like it.
I think the guy who does it the best is
Jimmy Kimmel.
I think Jimmy Fallon does a pretty good
too,
you know,
he's got.
He makes it fun.
He's got a lot of like fun things that
he does on it.
You know,
Seth Meyers is a good job making it fun
as well and he has some really good
points.
You know,
I show,
but I just think ultimately I can't.
I can barely express myself in five
minutes,
seven minutes,
you know,
and especially in front of a crowd,
you're sitting there in front of a crowd
and you want to talk about important
things or funny things are right tab.
Joe,
I understand that.
You don't like the zoo.
Tell us why you don't like the zoo.
It's a fucking animal prison and I think
it's fucked up.
I can even say those words.
Yeah,
it's.
I feel like there's A.
I think that people,
some people have a short attention span.
They don't want long things or whatever,
but I think that like a show like yours,
I think fills a niche assignment.
Interesting.
You'd show but fills this need that I
think is underrated that people like
long form things that they like depth,
that they have lots of time to burn when
they're driving around or at work in
their board or they're just cooking food
or whatever it is they're doing.
I used to have that argument in my old
company.
Where are we?
I was like,
you guys are just wrong when you make
the show three or four or five minutes
for them,
like,
no,
it'll be as long as I want it to be for
me to get my word out.
And I was right about that and I feel
like.
So I like the long form stuff.
I like for things to be as long as they
need to be and flush things out into not
corner people to let them express them,
explain themselves and stuff like that.
I think it's good.
That's why it show so popular,
you know?
And um,
you know,
I'm surprised that people aren't kind of
more,
more and more and more aping the idea of
doing,
going three,
four or five hours if necessary with
people.
Some people don't want to do it,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a uniquely blabber mouth type
person.
I can just keep talking about things
forever and also I'm not connected to
something else where I have to worry
about what I say,
you know,
like I can't get fired if I'm the boss.
I'm my own boss,
you know,
so a lot of people don't.
They're not in that position,
you know,
and they,
they really worry about putting their
foot in their mouth,
which I've definitely done a ton of
times and that,
that being the end of their career
instead of being what it is,
just a mistake,
you know,
and I think for people to really get a
sense of who you truly are,
you know,
you get a sense of who someone is over
three hours,
you really get a sense of who someone is
over three hours,
over a thousand,
200 podcasts,
where the fuck we've done,
what are we on thousand 20 or something
like that.
One thousand 32 plus fight companions.
A lot of fucking shows.
People get a sense of who you are.
You know,
it's um,
it's just different.
It's a different kind of thing,
you know,
uh,
a television show is a more polished,
edited.
It might be better for your attention
span me if this was on TV,
just regular TV,
maybe it would be a bomb,
you know,
maybe like uniquely fits into the
weirdness that is the internet.
That's why it's been successful.
And also I think it's probably been
successful because it was never,
there was never any attempt at being
successful.
It was,
it was never like something where I sat
out and go,
if I just do this a certain way,
it will be financially viable.
It will be received well and will,
I'll use this as a vehicle to further my
other endeavors.
There's never any thought process,
right that it's like,
hey,
be cool to just talk to people.
Hey,
think I can get Anthony Bordain come
over my house sitting right there,
let's give them some beers,
let's have talks,
you know.
And,
and that's where it all came from,
you know,
just came organically.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the beauty of it.
And I think that,
I think that shines through with your
showing up in some other people that
like you can tell when someone's putting
it on.
Someone mean I of.
I'm sure
you can.
What do you think you'd like to hope you
can?
Yeah,
sure.
Well Bill Cosby.
Yeah.
Who?
Yeah,
he bought it.
Probably would have failed both of us.
Maybe.
Maybe not though.
Me.
No.
And he never had.
That's part of the thing.
Like he might've fooled both of us if he
was on the tonight show,
but if he was sitting across the room
for us for three hours just talking
shit,
you know,
maybe not.
You know,
we never really gotten to.
Yeah,
right.
You must have been overdoing thousand
episodes,
many hundreds of guests.
You must,
you must learn a lot.
Like you were saying a lot about a
person,
but that.
Does your opinion of the person change
when you have some interesting
interviews with,
with bigger people,
for instance,
that come on your show better or worse?
Like after kind of poking and prodding
them for a little while?
Yeah.
But you,
I think you did data chunk right?
Whenever you're talking to people and
you,
you see sort of some sort of patterns in
deflection and communication and
openness and some people really impress
you with their honesty,
their thoughtfulness or objectivity.
Objectivity is a rare one.
Man,
that's a particularly rare thing where
so many people are so married to their
ideas and I try very hard not to be.
I'm certainly not perfect at it,
but I try very hard to not be married to
my ideas and if I'm wrong,
I really go out of my way to say,
wow,
I was definitely wrong about that.
Like I thought that was this,
but it's not.
It's that and this is,
this is how we know and here's the proof
now and here's the studies that have
come out.
Wow,
fucking that threw me for a loop.
But you have to.
You have to do that.
Absolutely.
But there are so many people that do not
want to ever admit fault and because of
that,
because you don't want to admit fault
because you don't want to admit that you
might've communicated in error or you
might've been misled by certain
information that you thought was true,
but turned out to not be.
It ruins the way people appreciate your
words because you could tell me that you
believe something happened in the past
because you read it because you learned
it in school because it's always been
taught that way,
but then new information comes out that
clearly refutes that.
You've got to come in here and say,
well now I know different,
but I thought this because I know that
you really did think that.
I know.
I know you were really being honest and
now I know you're being even more honest
because you're saying now we know
differently that now we know differently
is fucking giant map.
It's huge and you see it resisted.
You see a dissident academia.
You see it because people have been
teaching certain things for a certain
amount of time and then new evidence
comes to light and they don't want to
consider it.
He resisted at all.
Like I had a conversation once on the
radio with this lady who called up and
she was uh,
she was telling me that she was a
paleontologist.
Would who's studying monkeys?
The biologist would.
Would it be a biologist?
Yeah,
like some sort of,
some sort of a biologist.
And she said,
I have my phd because I was talking
about the Bondo ape,
which is a very particularly large
species.
The Congo and I was going over all these
different things about this app and it
was on the open anthony show and this
lady called up and she goes,
you are just talking about pseudo
science and cryptozoology you don't know
where you're talking about.
And I go,
no,
I'm reciting an article.
There was a national geographic.
This is all new information.
And I go,
she said she was a professor and I go,
when did you study?
When did you learn?
I go,
how,
how much time do you spend paying
attention to the newest,
latest information because clearly
you're wrong.
They have,
they have skulls,
they have videos of these animals.
They have photographs of them,
they have camera trap photos,
they have DNA on them.
They have a crest in their head like a
gorilla,
and I,
when I get obsessed with things,
I have an ability to rattle off
information or rattle off information.
This lady and she never says,
no,
you're wrong.
I mean,
she never says,
well,
I guess I was wrong.
I am going on old information.
She starts laughing and mocking me.
I go,
are you better than these scientists
that are in national geographic that are
putting out these photographs that are
spending years in the Congo?
Carl Jung,
the Swiss wildlife photographer that
spent years in the Congo photographing
these creatures.
They nest on the ground like gorillas.
There are particularly large species of
chimpanzees there.
So I started rattling off inflammation
and the lady's like,
you know,
like you don't know what you're talking
about.
I go,
you're not fucking saying anything.
You're not saying anything because you
know you don't have the latest
information.
That kinda shit drives me nuts when
someone doesn't really know but pretends
they know is presented with information
and isn't willing to accept it.
You know,
you got to be willing to accept
information.
Like this lady called up to try to like
to puff out her chest.
Like she has the information.
Like she's a,
she's a professor.
She knows,
but I'm not saying I'm not in the woods
studying.
I'm reading all these fucking biologists
who were there there.
This is amazing new discovery.
I mean there's a fucking giant champ
that lives in the Congo.
There's photos of this thing walking
around on two legs.
It's six feet tall.
I mean there's a huge chimpanzee.
It's far bigger than the other chimps.
They have two different types of champs.
They have treat the,
they call them tree beaters and and
ground something.
I forget the term they use,
but these larger chimps literally sleep
on the ground.
They don't give a fuck.
Nothing comes near them.
And the,
Oh the,
what they call them leopardy eaters,
but they've,
they have video of them,
one of them literally eating a leopard
and they don't know if it killed it.
They don't know if it found a dead,
but like if these motherfuckers can kill
leopards.
But if you think about how strong a
regular chimpanzee is,
you know,
a regular hundred and 50,
150 pound chimpanzee,
it's supposed to be as strong as a 500
pound man.
A lion killers.
That's what they call them.
These,
these are huge chimpanzees.
See if a pull up a photograph,
some of these fuckers,
but they have these,
one of these two guys shot at a,
at an airport and a small airport in the
Congo.
And there's these two guys standing
holding this carcass.
The righthand side,
third down far right hand side,
third down,
third down.
That's it.
Bam.
Go large on that.
Look at a size of that fucking thing.
That's a chimp.
It looks like a goddamn because the size
of his balls,
I mean that is a fucking huge
chimpanzee.
That's one that they found that,
that they had shot,
they took photographs of,
but if you go above that photo,
Jamie,
go above that photo to the,
to the upper right hand corner.
That's one that they caught walking
around on a,
on a camera trap.
They're just much,
much bigger than regular chimpanzees as
wild.
Yeah.
No Pun intended,
but the point was,
this is just,
it was an incidence of someone just
deciding that they had all the
information and that they wanted to just
call bullshit on something that they're
really.
They really weren't up to date on it.
Yeah.
I think pride gets in the way.
A lot of that I try my hardest and I
actually kind of gets to me when my
audience are people that watch my stuff,
say like,
Oh,
Colin didn't admit he was wrong about
this,
this or this.
I'm like,
I don't know that you're paying very
close attention because I actually take
a lot of pride in being wrong about
things sometimes and telling you that
I'm wrong,
so you know,
so you're not going out into the world
with misinformation.
Whether it was about video games back in
the day,
whether it's about politics or history.
I got,
when you're rattling things off,
like you were saying,
like when you're rattling things off,
sometimes you get things mixed up and
confused and things of like,
I don't even realize it while I'm saying
that I'm saying the wrong word or
someone's name wrong.
It happens.
And,
and I,
I think that it's,
I think it's essential to do those kinds
of things.
And it,
it,
it's,
it represents an academic stagnance when
you don't want to do that.
I certainly,
um,
even though I consider myself again a
moderate conservative,
I certainly have been playing around
intentionally with really challenging
ideas lately to try to,
um,
you know,
specifically with universal basic income
and,
and Medicare for all where I'm like,
I'm fundamentally principally probably
against these things.
But if you can show me how they work,
if I can read some data,
we can get some test cases.
I know they're testing ubi in places
like Sweden.
Then I want to see what it's all about
because this is so uncomfortable.
This is so out of,
out of whack for me that I want to know,
you know,
how it works and I think with you on
that one,
by the way.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's an interesting one.
And I believe they're testing it in some
someplace in the United States.
Are they?
Yeah.
I think somewhere in the United States
going to test universal basic income.
So you have a good find that this like
fairly recently over the last few days.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's just fascinating to kind of get out
of your head,
you know,
I've been dealing with this idea of this
idea of rights versus privileges and how
were we call a lot of things rights,
but they're not right.
There's no right to medical the medical
care that they'll write to that.
But the idea of A.
I hate when people.
I guess it's a right to,
to.
It's human,
right?
Yeah.
It's not.
You have a right to,
you're an alien.
All right.
So the whole life and liberty and stuff
like that,
those are rights.
You don't have a right to force someone
to do something for you,
is essentially
what you're forcing a doctor to work on
you if you don't have the money to pay
for it.
Exactly,
but I think as a culture we should
probably put that in terms of like what
are we going to do for our citizens?
What we would definitely going have
provide fire protection.
We're definitely going to provide
police.
We should definitely provide medical
too.
I'm just think it's.
It should be.
There should be a safety net to keep
people healthy if they don't have money.
Sure.
I think that it's a,
it's a totally valid thing to say,
uh Oh,
what do we have it is.
Whereas this,
they randomly selected 3000 individuals
across two US states participate in this
study.
1,000
received a thousand dollars per month
for up to five years in 2000 will
receive $50 per month.
What does that,
and it's the control for the,
for the express serve as a control group
for comparison with the $50 for is not
going to help shit,
but the thousand dollars per month that
that's.
That gets interesting because then
you're not giving anybody enough where
they can fuck off because 250 bucks is
really not going to pay for rent and
food,
but it's a.
it'll help you give you like a little
bit of a boost.
Yeah.
It could be good for the economy.
I think that there's.
There's a lot of worry about inflation
because you're basically freeing up a
ton of money that would otherwise be in
banks are not circulating on the market,
so it's gonna make your dollar less
valuable.
I think there's a lot of like
complicated things economically that
people have to deal with with that,
but I feel like you know,
with what you were talking about with
healthcare,
I think it's an interesting point
because we don't.
We talk too much about rights and we
have these rights.
You have a right to not be searched
without a warrant.
You have a right to due process,
his free speech rights,
right,
um,
that are written in the bill of rights
and the constitution,
but,
but privileges a 21st century modern,
progressive,
wealthy society.
What can your privileges of being part
of that society?
And I,
I like when people talk about it in that
sense and be like medical care as a part
of it is the privilege of being part of
a like this.
I'm like,
okay,
so let's frame the art.
Let's frame the arguments differently
because I think it's a more compelling
way to say we've achieved so much.
We're not in the dark ages anymore.
We're not even in the 18th or 19th
centuries anymore.
Now we have roads,
we have police and fire,
we have all these things.
What's to stop us from having the
privilege of having this as well.
And I think it's just frame it that way
and you'll have way more people on board
and it's a very compelling argument for
why we shouldn't spend $800 billion on
the military.
Like maybe if you had some of that money
freed up,
you could take care of a lot of things
at home.
You could,
uh,
medical care of Medicare for all is
expensive.
It's extremely expensive.
Streamline.
You could,
you could actually,
as far as I understand,
you could,
I think tax,
I'm sorry,
you could remove military spending
completely and pay for only like a
fourth of it.
So it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a really radically.
Really?
Yeah,
I think so.
$800,
billion dollars a year would only pay
for a fourth.
I think it's 600 billion a year of
spending military spending right now.
But I think it's,
it's uh,
Jamie,
do you mind,
I hate to ask you to do something,
but do you mind looking to see how much
the Medicare for all thing?
Cause I think it's something like one
point 5 trillion a year,
so like 2 trillion a year or something
like that.
Shit.
And so like these are the things,
but you have to have rational
conversations with why I have no respect
for Bernie Sanders because you can just
throw things out there.
Yeah.
One
point $4,000,000,000,000,
so you get Medicare for all plan cost
nearly one point 4 trillion.
So a little off.
So it's a little less than half.
You actually you could.
He's,
he's a character.
Well,
it's easy to.
It's easy to go around promising things
to people.
Like the funny thing is like Free
College,
right?
Like free,
nothing's free,
but free college.
It's like,
well you're 401k is going to tax for
that.
If you're,
if you're a middle class family and
you're making transaction walter
transactions,
broker transactions with your forum,
okay,
you're going to pay that tax.
You know,
it's easy to say Medicare for all by
raising taxes.
But everyone's taxes go up two point two
percent,
you know,
not.
I think there's also a real
concern with kids fucking off with that
education.
Like if a,
if an education costs like what is um,
uh,
per year cost of a very good university
today.
Oh,
not even like an Ivy League University,
but
probably 20,
$25,000
a year.
That's a lot of money
if you're just giving that to some kid
and they half ass their education and
they don't get kicked out of school and
it's free like,
well,
maybe that's not the best use of money,
but if someone can demonstrate a real
desire to learn,
you know,
and a real desire to achieve and to
discipline themselves into following
through with the courses and doing the
work,
you maybe then maybe give someone a
semester for free and proved by their
performance in that semester by their
effort,
their performance,
how much work they've done that you
know,
okay,
you,
it's very likely that you can get
through four years of this university
and get out with a bachelor's degree.
Maybe even move on and continue your
education or become a really valuable
member of our society and benefit our
economy and benefit our.
So our civilization,
because of what you're learning here.
So making an investment in you mean
that?
I think that's a valuable thing for our
country,
right?
Have more educated,
less ignorant people have less losers,
right?
Yeah.
I think to me,
I say this,
I guess we're a pace of place of some
privileges.
I went to college,
I went to a great college and I'm proud
of that,
but at the same time I feel like it's
too.
Why don't we emphasize trade schools
anymore?
Why don't we emphasize that you don't
have to go to college,
you can be an entrepreneur,
you can start a business.
I feel like it's all.
It's often too,
it's too much focused on like an
academic path and I'm like,
that's good for some people,
but I would argue that there's probably
too many people going to college,
especially for things that we were
talking about earlier on that don't
really do anything for you.
If you have a chemistry degree or a
physics degree or a math degree,
you're going to be great.
If you have a history degree like I did,
you have to be very lucky like I was or
your.
You might have some hard times,
you know,
or you find something else to do.
Exactly.
Every benefit.
Just from the discipline that you
learned while you were in school.
Right?
Exactly.
It's,
it's,
it's proof that you can accomplish
something,
but I wish that there was more drive to
say like we need plumbers,
we need electricians,
we need.
And you know what?
Two things,
some of the stupidest people I've ever
met went to college.
Some of the smartest people I've ever
met,
he didn't go to college and some of the
people that I know that are doing the
best economically are in trades,
not,
they don't have a degree.
They're electricians,
they,
they build houses,
they do those kinds of things.
Repair.
Exactly.
These are essential and these things
aren't going away either.
So it's,
I feel like,
you know,
I look at someone like a mechanic,
I look at it,
a plumber or something like that.
I'm like,
man,
that's really impressive because I don't
know what the hell you're doing,
you know,
but you,
you know how to wire this house,
you know,
how to,
to lay the plumbing,
you know,
how to do all these kinds of things.
That's a vital service.
And so.
Exactly.
So I feel like there's almost this like
got to go to college,
got to go to college.
I'm like,
no you don't,
and and the other thing that I think is
really relevant is that I paid for my
college and now suddenly and I'm paying
loans out the ass for my college degree
still and I have to now pay for someone
else's college like and that I,
I did what I had to do and I don't
really feel like it's fair that I had to
owe 60 or $70,000
in loans that I've paid back,
but someone and then I have to pay
taxes,
extra taxes for someone else to go to
college as well.
It kind of frustrates me in specifically
because the only reason college is so
expensive is because the government is
involved in the loans,
subsidized loans.
Anyone can get a loan.
If you,
if you in a college and you knew that
anyone that came to you could just go
get a stafford loan,
right?
You would jack prices up in two seconds.
Of course he would make the loans more,
a more rare and even raise interest
rates on those loans and watch what
happens to the cost of college.
It will plummet because they can't
justify the cost anymore.
The government made this problem.
Now the government's trying to,
and this is what I'm talking about,
the government's not trying to solve a
problem.
It Matt,
it totally manufactured on its own.
When did that all begin?
I don't know.
I think I,
I don't know for sure.
I think in the seventies it began and
then I think it really got out of
control in the nineties,
you know,
because I went to northeastern and my
mom actually worked there,
so I didn't even pay tuition.
I only paid room and board tuition in
northeastern is like $45,000
or something a year now.
I know people that went to college that
had to pay out,
have those loans strapped to.
They have two kids in college.
Holy Shit.
That's incredible.
Like,
Holy Shit.
And Dude,
I don't,
I don't know what I was,
you know,
when you're 17 or 18 years old,
I remember my dad,
my dad's,
my dad's in New York City,
firefighter.
Very serious guy.
Right?
And I remember him sitting down and
being like,
I'm taking these loans out for you,
I'm coast signing on them and,
and him kind of looking at me in the eye
and be like,
you will not default on these loans.
You know,
like he's like,
I know you don't understand it.
Yeah.
Like being like,
because you're 17 or 18 years old being
like,
yeah,
I don't remember what the fuck is going,
I'm going to college,
I'm going to,
you know,
I'm going,
do whatever I'm going to do.
Look at that.
We really got to control what is the
ADC.
So like in the mid,
early to mid eighties is when it got out
of control.
And then in the nineties the separation,
now look it goes to 2009,
but in 2009 it's just through the
fucking roof.
It's just so the government,
the government did this and now they're
trying to solve.
Now Bernie Sanders is running around
trying to solve the problem.
It's like,
and speaking of age and stuff like the
Democrat,
he's absolutely going to try to run
again.
And we're going to.
I think so,
so old and he'll be 80.
His,
his head is leaning forward.
Look,
someone's got to teach them to stand up
straight.
Yeah,
he's got,
he's just got that bookish Kinda,
you know,
he's got this thing going on where his
head is like slowly making its way down
to his sternum.
You know,
he's
collapsing like,
like Bernie.
This is really bad for you though.
That's the thing.
That's my look.
He would have one.
Um,
I think if he went up against trump,
I think he would have done much better
than Hillary.
It's a brand of populism that would have
been.
So I think something like 10 percent of
people that voted for him in the primary
voted for trump.
So that's a compelling number that
suggests what you say is right.
But my whole,
the x factor in this is the oppo
research and you got a little bit of
taste of what research is.
Oppo,
oppo opposition research that they never
used on Bernie Sanders because they
didn't have to.
And the Republicans have all sorts of
stuff on him and it's not even he went,
you know,
like little things that resonate with
older people.
Right.
So like they went,
him and Jane Sanders went on their
honeymoon to the Soviet Union.
That's really weird,
right?
Fucking Russians.
People that are 20 or 25 don't care
about that.
People that are 40,
45,
50 care a lot about that,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
went to a communist country to explore
the great benefits of the fucking red
flag,
which of which there are none,
just like Lee Harvey Oswald cool domes
in their building.
Very unique building.
Good architecture.
Yeah.
I keep asking people though,
because everyone,
you know,
that you have these crazy people on
twitter and stuff that have the hammer
and sickle and their names and stuff
like that.
And I'm like,
can anyone tell me one thing that the
Soviet Union gave us?
Like gave the world one thing that
anyone that anyone cares about.
Yeah.
But that's Russian.
That's not even Soviet.
Right?
Like tetris came from the Soviet Union
in the game.
Yeah.
That might be the most important thing.
Good.
God Damn game communism is so morally
and intellectually bankrupt.
It's incredible to me that anyone would
even argue it.
It's just as morally and intellectually
bankrupt as the far right,
you know,
that seems to be the thing that people
go to when they look at some sort of a
viable alternative without looking into
a deeply Marxism,
you know,
and that this idea of socialism is going
to be a good thing because everybody's
going to contribute and capitalism is
what's wrong with the world.
And like,
Ooh,
and whenever people,
they,
they always like to hit up this fucking
thing of,
you know,
uh,
the,
the economic inequality,
economic inequality and inequality of
income,
inequality of money.
But what people don't seem to get is
that when you have true freedom,
you're absolutely going to have
inequality.
Because if you have the true freedom to
do whatever you want,
some people aren't going to do much and
some people are going to do a lot is
going to be some Jeff Bezos types
characters out there who just want to
fucking go gangbusters and own half the
country.
And then there's going to be people that
would really rather just work a little
bit and then go play fucking disc golf
and smoke pot and listen to records and
hang out with their friends.
And they'd be very happy if they just
made an income that was sustainable.
There's,
there's a host of different
personalities.
There's some people that really enjoy
doing art and they liked to go down to a
fucking farmer's market and set up shop
and sell their artwork.
And that's fine for them.
They,
that's what they want to do.
That's how they want to live their life.
And maybe their dad was a fucking doctor
who died at 55 of a heart attack because
he was working too hard.
Or you know,
who knows what it is that causes someone
have the ambition or
the desires that they have.
But when you have true freedom to pursue
whatever you want,
that literally breeds inequality.
Because there are going to be people
that decide to do more.
And there's going to be people in,
whether it's a,
an egalitarian version of this,
whether these people are altruistic in
their approach,
whether they're,
uh,
the,
they donate an incredible amount to
charity or whether or not they keep it
all to themselves.
If you have real freedom like that
doesn't say you have to donate x amount
of your money to this and y amount of
your money to that.
If you just give people freedom,
you're going to have any quality because
people are in equal in their efforts.
They're equal in their desires,
their equal in their focus.
They're equal in their discipline.
You are and there are equal in their
capabilities.
Yup.
No,
that's the major thing.
That's a big one that people don't want
to talk about anymore.
I often,
yes,
I asked.
It's kind of a rough thing to say,
but I've had conversations with people
where I'm like,
when did people stop saying like,
wow,
that kid is just dumb.
Like like,
like I remember even growing up in the
eighties and early nineties where like,
it's like some dms guild,
there's nothing wrong with them,
you know,
they don't have a disability or anything
like that,
but it's just like this kid doesn't
really have the capability of going,
he's going to do something else with his
life now it's like everyone can do
anything at any given time.
And I'm like,
no,
you work,
you have some innate quality to you but
your work,
you study,
you,
you toil,
you do those kinds of things.
Not Everything is,
is delivered on a platter to everyone.
And I re,
I almost resent that,
you know,
because some people really work very
hard and some people don't work hard at
all.
And then like you're saying the outcome
should be equal.
I don't think so.
It is some people that are tall,
there's some people that are short and
there's some people that have brains
that are made at a dog shit and there's
not much you can do about that.
There is absolutely a broad spectrum of
human intelligence,
of awareness and you know how much of
that is the environment they grew up in,
how much of that is their education,
how much of that is there a Bra?
Genetics,
who knows,
and there's environmental factors that
fuck people up,
right?
Like this.
This is real arguments that are living
around toxic waste is very damaging to
your Iq.
You know there's,
there's a lot going on with human beings
and it's not fair,
but here when you play cards,
okay,
if you hit four aces and I get one too
and a bunch of fucking random numbers,
that's not fair either,
but I have to figure out a way to win
with this hand.
You know,
or get by and if it truly is a
competition and you got a shitty hand,
you got to do your best,
do your best with the hand you got.
You know,
if you are a dwarf and you want to be a
basketball player,
you're going to have to let that go.
You can't do that.
You know what else you can't do?
You can't fly.
You can't breathe under water,
you can't see through walls,
you know,
you can't run a million miles an hour.
Okay.
Those were the things you can't do,
so let's,
let's figure out what you can do and
find something that you can be
passionate about.
And I think capitalism as an economic
system,
the only one that I ca that accommodates
all right.
And I exactly it it,
it's,
it's such a trite thing,
but it's like it's the least imperfect
of all the systems,
right?
Like there's nothing positive about
something like communism.
To me,
I think like whenever I see that hammer
and sickle
and I don't mean to be mean,
whenever I see that hammer and sickle on
a person's name,
I'm like,
I'm not really dealing with someone with
a full deck.
I don't think.
Like,
I don't know how you can possibly like
read Marx and do all these kinds of
things.
Jumped deep into history.
Look at the Soviet Union,
look at North Korea,
look at Cuba,
look at all of the failure that's
happening all around you.
Then look at the fact that everyone is
benefiting from capitalism in some way.
They're just doing it wrong,
yet it's not real communism.
It's not real socialism.
That's always this.
It was the answer.
I mean real capitalism.
The worst aspects of capitalism are
diminishing appreciation for the human
being and the fact that money is power
over everything and that people just
acquire material goods and all those
things are true,
but they're true at the farthest end of
the spectrum of good to bad,
right?
The furthest end of like,
what is the damage that capitalism can
do well can you can devalue human life
to the point where money becomes more
and more powerful than anything and
people can consolidate this money and
build these all girl family structures
and you know there's a lot of issues
that can happen,
but that can happen with anything where
people have leverage and power over
other people.
It doesn't necessarily mean they have to
happen that way.
There's,
there's got to be some evidence and some
instances,
instances of altruistic.
I'm a capitalist.
I'm like,
Bill Gates for instance.
That guy does a lot of really good
things,
you know,
and his,
the Bill Gates Foundation and that he.
He has started up,
I mean,
God damn,
he's donated.
A shitload of money will go to charity.
I mean,
that's a good example.
Another good example is Warren Buffet.
Warren Buffet has,
I believe,
donating almost all of his money to
charities.
I mean,
and these are guys that are wildly
successful.
I mean you're talking billions and
billions of dollars in wealth attained
entirely through capitalism.
It like,
so you have your bad examples,
but you also have good examples.
I mean,
what Bill Gates has done,
I mean really incredibly impressive when
you stop and think about it,
get the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation,
wherever they call it,
is like super influential.
Uh,
I,
I look at it in the sense of yes,
there are negatives about all of these
things like you were saying,
but I also feel like,
are you eating today in half the world?
Because that's because of capitalism.
Are you,
you know,
like capitalism,
the industrial revolution that,
that got,
that got everything going in the last
150 years is all because of the
necessity of,
of the chase of the dollar or the pound
or whatever the case might be.
Like the chase for money is not in
itself a negative thing.
It's what you're saying,
what you do with it.
And the ramifications of what we get
because of money,
you know,
is an amazing thing.
I often talk about whether it's good or
bad is,
you know,
when apple one,
the apple one computer was being made in
the mid seventies,
you know,
Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs used to go
to this thing called homebrew Computer
Club in Berkeley.
And people would go there.
There was this real spirit in the
seventies amongst tinkerers that they
would share their stuff with each other,
that they would be like,
this is how I did this.
This is how I programmed this very
rudimentary punch card machine.
This is.
And they were going with apple one to
this thing and uh,
Wazniak had really
wanted to give it away to be like this
revolutionary computer that we are
sitting on here.
We're just going to give you the tools
to make your own.
Steve jobs was the one that said like,
we have something here that can become
more ubiquitous if we make it into a
product that we sell as opposed to
something that stays within the confines
of the Berkeley homebrew computer club
were at 15.
People will enjoy it.
We can mark it this bad boy.
And so it takes sometimes a person who
has the most number,
it costs $766 and 66,
four K of Ram ram rather.
That's amazing.
So you know what I'm saying?
Like it takes some times for things to
proliferate.
Sometimes for things to do good,
there has to be a profit motive and
sometimes you need a steve jobs who
didn't have the intellect.
That was me.
I had on a programming perspective,
but saw products for what they were.
Went into Xerox,
saw the guy,
saw the mouse,
saw the ethernet cable,
knew what to do with these different
things.
That's the beauty of capitalism to me.
You know,
that's one incentive for him to pursue
these goals.
Exactly,
and we all benefit.
Look at,
look at our smart phones.
Ten years ago that we'd had no idea what
these things are going to become and
look at the economy.
They opened up 10 years ago.
You were psyched if your phone flipped
open.
Yeah,
it was all he could do that thing with
the risk where had opened without you.
Yeah.
Kirk out slap it shut.
Do you remember the matrix phone when it
came out?
Like it shot open and they're like,
no one could ever get one and now I feel
like a lot of people one on one.
Do you remember that at all?
What's the major phone that when the
matrix came out,
the first,
the first one,
they all had a cell phone.
It was made by Sony and the bottom of it
shot out.
Instead of flipping open,
you like hit a little button and it's
like he jumped down and it never was
released for like a consumer.
Why not?
Capitalism wasn't already late.
Capitalism wasn't ready for that phone.
Bernie Sanders were released for free
for him.
I think he's in unique character because
he's an antiestablishment character.
He's interesting.
Well,
that goes back to the point you were
making.
That's why he came up is because you
said he could maybe be trump.
I think the shared populous message here
it is
version of it might've finally came out
I guess,
but um,
how does it work?
I'm confused that this shot out and it's
just covered up the thing instead of
flipping open.
Oh,
it's like you press a button and it
slides down.
Yeah.
I mean that's when they were running and
like trinity was running shoe,
just do it.
And they were like,
we need an operator.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Isn't it crazy that we thought that was
the shit?
It's not even that long ago.
That's what's so funny about it,
you know?
Well,
I had a blackberry.
I thought it was a wizard for super
technological too.
I had a blackberry.
Is that it?
It slides open spiral.
It has a screen and the bottom.
Isn't that funny?
They never thought you would ever be
able to type on a screen.
Like that's just ridiculous.
Get the fuck out of here with that.
You need buttons,
man.
Remember that?
One of them bitches.
I had one of those with the keyboard.
I love that thing.
It's great and send emails.
I never did,
but you could,
but you could.
Yeah,
you could.
If you wanted to send half my emails on
my phone.
Now I think about like I love thinking
about the iphone and the smartphone
revolution and then all of the
businesses that are totally based on
that thing,
that uber or
a Lyft,
all of these companies that only exist
because that product existed only
because someone saw the capital
investment necessary to proliferate this
thing and I think it's amazing as it is
and communism doesn't give you that
exactly as you're saying.
Them in capitalism is responsible for
this intense competition and these cats
and these smartphones now where they are
legitimate contenders to apple.
Now like apple just released the iphone
10 or the x,
whatever the fuck they're going to call
it,
but you have legitimate contenders in
the Samsung Galaxy.
Note eight,
the Galaxy s eight and the Google Pixel
two xl.
You have these three phones that a lot
of people compare favorably to the
iphone.
They're going back and forth with this
and it's like it's a neck and neck race.
Now.
It's a matter of whether or not the
integration with the operating system is
important to you because a lot of people
enjoy using a Mac and an apple computer
and you know,
they want to have the phone seamlessly
integrated with the computer and then a
lot of other people use windows and they
prefer to use an android phone because
of that.
So it's,
you're,
you're dealing with massive competition
now,
which is fueling apple to innovate,
fueling samsung to innovate and me,
right now it's just phones and you know,
who knows whether or not it's really
important to us,
but that could lead to bigger and better
things.
No one saw the smartphone coming and
that's really revolutionized the way we
exchange information,
the way we gather information,
Google's new pixel xl,
you squeeze the side and ask you a
question,
like that's how quick the assistant
comes in as well.
So you squeeze the side and you say,
tell me who Collin Moriarty is.
Bam.
It shows you instantaneous,
a sexist pig,
a joke,
and he should die.
What does that Jamie foldable screens
that are headed out the next couple of
years.
Excellent.
The next thing,
what the fuck,
man,
it's crazy.
This slap wrist thing where you're
talking about with the fucking tape
measures and as you know Korean company,
lg is doing this for altruistic reasons.
They're not going to make any money.
They don't see any money in the foldable
skirt.
Pull it.
Bernie Sanders.
Yeah.
He's going to support his neck with one
of those phones.
Get when them bitches just shoot under
to keep his head above water.
I get a phone call.
I looked down.
He,
I think we're in an incredible time when
it comes to this competition though,
and you're right,
that only exists if people have profit.
You only exist that people have some
sort of A.
There's competition and there's an
incentive and you know,
it was.
There's a battle going on between these
and I think that's the forefront of it
because with laptops,
I mean there's competition but boys
kinda stagnant,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
well how much processing power do you
need?
If you're not rendering video games,
if you're not making things,
if you're not making movies,
if you're a person that's making CGI or
filmed or something like that,
well then it makes sense.
You could probably use the faster
processors and all the power and stuff
like that,
but really the competition is in video
games and in or in a video and apps and
phones and the images these phones can
create and all of them now have the
ability to do portrait mode where they
blur the background and bring you into
the foreground and then the Google Pixel
xl has some incredible ai for altering
images and making them look cooler and
it's really amazing stuff,
man.
Yeah,
it's awesome and I.
I feel like a lot of the cool stuff that
we even dwell on from back in the day,
everything had a profit motive back in.
Especially like we were talking about
the age of exploration,
like they weren't looking.
They didn't want to come here.
The Europeans were just looking for a
way to shorten their trade with Asia.
They didn't care about what was in
between.
It was actually,
it's super inconvenient that we were
here,
you know,
like there was always money at the end
of the tunnel for like good things.
So that's why.
That's what the space race,
that's why the space race is so unique
because it had no,
you know,
like everything from like mercury and
Gemini.
Apollo missions had like no real reason
to exist.
Other than that we wanted the best,
the communist,
there was no financial reason to do it,
which is why it's so unique.
And,
and I,
I would even argue to this day like
there's technology that NASA is created
that we find in our everyday lives,
but it's like one of those unique places
where that's not really true,
but there's also
right that subsistence living probably
makes healthier,
happier people.
And then all this chasing money and
chasing innovation and chasing,
you know,
technological superiority just leaves us
with this hollow feeling or it doesn't
do you any good.
Like you're seeing a lot of these people
that.
There was this guy that we were talking
about recently,
the guy who he coded facebook likes and
now he,
your computer is trying to hijack your
brain,
I think is the name of the article.
Your smartphone is trying to hijack your
brain.
And what it was essentially saying is
that your brain is not designed to deal
with the reward system that's involved
in checking likes on facebook or
instagram or stuff like that.
And that,
these things,
these,
this constant like,
um.
Um,
I,
uh,
yesterday we were talking about this.
We were talking about,
uh,
I had Jamie Kilstein,
he was talking about checking his phone,
like constantly checking twitter on his
phone and arguing back and forth with
people.
Seeing who supporting him,
who's not in that it becomes this
massive addictive thing and that how
unhealthy that is.
You know,
it's like there's a lot of things about
this technological world that we live in
that maybe aren't sustainable or aren't
compatible with being a biological human
being.
I agree.
It's hated,
mentioned again,
but there's an episode of Black Mirror
where there's this one person in this
cast where they refuse to get this,
this augment that everyone else has.
I want to read it for you anymore.
And it makes them this unique thing
because they refuse to partake in the
new normal of interconnectivity.
And uh,
it's,
again,
it goes back to the beauty of the system
that there is choice.
Like you were saying,
the Bohemian painter that just wants to
make $15,000
a year selling some art.
That's the beauty of choice.
Yeah,
exactly.
And as long as the system gives you that
choice to succeed or fail and no one
else is responsible for you,
like in,
in,
in base ways.
And I'm not saying we're not responsible
to bring you to the hospital if you're
sick.
I'm not saying any of that,
but we're not responsible to make
decisions for you.
We're not responsible to line your
pockets with money.
You did not.
All right.
And then that's,
that's,
that's fine with me.
That's one of the awful things
about communism that people very rarely
discussed.
You're assigned,
signed a job,
you're assigned what you do if you live
in Cuba.
I mean there's very little wiggle room
as to what you can and can't do if you
were living in the Communist.
Soviet Union is very little.
You don't.
You don't have a whole lot of decision
making capabilities and that's just not
how human beings operate at their best.
We operate at our best when we're free.
When you are uniquely you,
you're not me.
I'm not you.
I don't.
I don't know how your brain works and
there's people out there like,
I dunno,
here's an example back that are so weird
and so different from me,
but he's capable of creating weird
fucking funky music because he's so
different because he's so interesting,
right?
Like his form of Marilyn Manson,
his form of creativity just doesn't
work.
My brain doesn't make that.
You know,
like a tomato tree doesn't make mangoes.
and we're,
we're are the freedom to express
yourself in your own unique way and the
freedom to live your life with your own
unique direction.
That's just one of the greatest things
about being an American is that we have
more freedom in that regard than anyone
that's ever lived because we have more
access to things,
we have more access to information and
we have more freedom to choose to
express yourself,
to speak out,
and anything that gets in the way from
that,
including the limiting free speech on
campuses is fucking dangerous in that
regard because it,
you don't,
you think you're helping,
but you're,
you're limiting freedom.
You're limiting freedom because it
doesn't jive with what's going on in
your head and that's just not the way
it's supposed to work.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I agree with you.
I find what's happening on college
campuses.
I find the stymieing of free speech,
this idea,
this very primitive idea that we are
this primitive notion of almost thought
policing,
um,
as being super unsavory because you have
to protect,
you have to.
A society needs to be dedicated to
protecting its bad elements as long as
those elements aren't illegal.
Right?
So like you don't want to protect the
person who is murdering someone,
but you might want to protect someone
who you might want to protect the rights
of someone who is espousing really
racist shit because you you.
That's why these protections exist is
for their freedom to express those bad
ideas.
As long as they don't play out,
you don't have to agree with them.
You and I don't agree with those ideas,
but you give them oxygen and power.
When you try to limit them,
I,
I guarantee you that because of the,
the,
the throwing around at the majority of
not ism and as a pejorative Nazis and
fascism and kind of giving these people
screentime,
Richard Spencer and all these guys,
I guarantee you that they've gained in
adherence,
not lost because they're gaining more
and more oxygen because you're giving it
to them by trying to stymie them.
You're bringing attention to them.
I said over and over again with Milo
Yiannopoulos going to Berkeley earlier
this year and then not being allowed to
speak and everyone losing their minds.
You just gained Milo Yiannopoulos,
a bunch of people that had no idea who
he was.
The thing that would have hurt him the
most is going to a room that was empty,
that would.
No one was there to speak,
but he has the right to go to that room
and speaking on the less well.
What's interesting is what's kind of
like silenced
him is his own words.
I mean his own,
what fucked him up.
His,
his own conversations,
his,
his ability to freely speak about
pedophilia,
right?
Give them,
it goes back to the give the person
enough rope and they'll do the job for
you.
You know,
like you don't have to,
you know,
you don't have to do it.
You don't have to force a square peg
into a round hole.
When I think of a lot of ways,
Milo is a provocateur and what he's
trying to do is trying to push buttons
and get attention and doing all those
things.
But in literally doing that and just
ranting and raving,
he tripped over his own dick.
You know,
the publishing company removes the book.
I mean,
that's a leaves.
Breitbart.
I mean,
this is essentially where all this came
from.
Yeah,
there's no.
I think what people kind of conflate is
there's room and necessity for
consequences for your actions.
There's no.
There's no one's saying that there's no
consequences.
Consequences seem to be taking place in
the marketplace of free ideas.
Right?
It's,
you can't.
I feel like people have tried to force
consequences on me,
for instance,
right.
They tried to.
They tried to force a consequence that
didn't work out the way that they wanted
it to,
but to try to make a point.
Right.
To try to illustrate a point,
but you have to let these things,
like you said,
the marketplace will correct for
anything that is on toward Kevin Spacey
is going to be hurting for the rest of
his life compared to where he was just
five days ago because the consequences
of his actions.
Right,
exactly.
So I'm not saying that there shouldn't
be consequences.
I don't think a lot of people are saying
that at all,
but I feel like it's almost,
it's not policing like there are
preemptive consequences,
but these consequences should be like,
hey,
we don't want to do business with you
because you and your values don't align
with how we look at the world.
You,
but you're free to do your own thing.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I.
Yeah,
and that's why I'm saying like you just
were giving,
were giving unsavory far right and far
left elements,
way too much oxygen and way too much
power in our society.
They don't represent anyone.
Like when you really,
when you walk through your life,
how many people do you know that a
scribe to Marxism?
How many people do you know that a
scribe to white nationalism.
I have never met in my own 33 years on
this planet in interacting with a ton of
different people.
I'm not sure I've ever actually met a
white nationalist,
so why are we acting like this is a like
a massive component of American politics
when it's not.
It's probably $2,350
million that live here,
just lob off the ends of the spectrum.
The far end of the spectrum is lob them
off.
They're not welcome in polite society.
They can do whatever they want.
Everyone else I bet has 90 percent
agreement on most issues and I think
that this intense heated,
screaming and yelling at each other that
you see like on Berkeley and Antifa
showing up with fucking Ninja masks on
throwing Molotov cocktails.
This ain't helping anybody know.
Anthony's just ramps up the other side.
Antifa like these guys are losers,
right?
Like,
like how dare you.
They,
they,
they supported by the mayor of Berkeley.
Yeah.
I'm sure a lot of weird things are
supported by the mayor of Berkeley.
Uh,
but yeah,
it doesn't help any situations they look
like they're like Cobra officers from Gi
Gel running around doing their thing,
destroying private property.
It doesn't make any sense.
Like why you would do this hero own
society to your own what,
what
books,
what it is anxious to like,
what point are you trying to prove and
and you're seeing this replicate itself
a lot.
I know it's an unpopular thing to say,
but you can draw this.
A lot of this back of the Ferguson even,
you know,
like Ferguson.
See in some ways ferguson is a travesty
of justice,
right?
But it seemed way worse than it actually
was once everything came out once,
once Loretta Lynch,
not a very well known racist,
refused to try the person at the federal
level,
local and state authorities,
grand juries refuse to try Darren Wilson
for what he did to the,
to the gentleman there or whatever and
you and you get the full story and yet
you still have this society or the
community in ruins based on some hands
up.
Don't shoot,
never happened,
right?
But literally never happened.
But this is the rallying cry.
This,
this destroyed city.
The rallying cry from as it sounds good
to people that want to believe a certain
narrative.
And so they repeated and then
everybody's repeating it.
And then you have people doing it on
television and then everybody decides
that this is the thing that we're going
to say over and over again,
regardless of whether or not it's true.
The real travesty of that too is that
you can literally throw a dart at a map
of the United States and find a civil
rights thing that's truly a civil rights
infraction that's truly horrible.
That probably deserves the oxygen and
the attention and could be a legitimate
rallying cry,
but it goes back to the point you were
making before too.
People don't want to admit they're
wrong.
No one wants to admit that.
Like a year out from Ferguson were much
further than that,
but even six months out from when it
happened,
people look back,
read through the grand jury stuff,
the federal government's take on it,
all that kind of stuff and realize,
oh,
maybe this wasn't the best idea that to
to to act like this when we didn't have
all the information.
So you think that the information is
flowing freer and people have more of an
understanding than ever before.
I think people are really doubling down
on the far right and the far left and
the extremism is sort of elevated in the
in that regard,
but I think overall,
I think,
you know,
people don't like the word Centrus,
but the people in the center of the
people that are more reasonable are more
informed and more.
There's more communication going on than
ever before and in that sense,
I'm very hopeful.
I am hopeful to.
I,
I like how centrism has become this
dirty,
like unspoken word.
It's,
it's,
but that's only again from the far
fringes that feel like they're losing
because they are losing.
If your idea is predicated on a race,
if like your idea of supremacy or
superiority as a predicate on that,
you're a moron,
right?
And no one does.
No one has to talk to you about that.
You don't deserve to be part of the
rational adult conversation.
Foolish notion.
If your idea on the left is that you
have to stymie free speech,
that free speech is this antiquated
thing.
I tweeted out a video last week,
have a kid at the University of Utah
saying that the.
I retweeted it.
Oh,
thank you.
Of saying the.
The.
Yeah,
like the tickets,
like a valid document.
Yeah.
I don't think it's about.
Yeah,
no,
there's nothing valid about the bill of
rights.
You Moron,
you know,
there's nothing like if your idea is is
Marxism and this weird economic
engineering and all this kind of stuff,
you are also a moron and,
and I'm not afraid to tell you that,
you know,
you have to have,
you have to be academically limited to
look at either of those ideas on this,
on this,
on these spectrums and think that you
have a good idea.
You know,
usually a collection of ideas not from
the but a collection of left,
right.
Liberal,
conservative usually is probably what's
right.
No one in the mainstream of American
politics or mainstream of Western
politics has a monopoly on right or a
monopoly on good ideas.
There are,
there are great things that Republicans
believe in.
There are great things that Democrats
believe.
There are terrible ideas on both sides.
The only thing I see on the extremes is
just a complete dearth of good ideas.
It's just all bad ideas,
just all terrible ideas.
And so why are we even paying attention
to them?
They can kick and scream and shout all
they want,
but we're giving them too much time on,
on,
uh,
you know,
the news,
we're giving them too much time.
Even even I do it even I fall prey to
that because it's fun.
It is just that little fucker on TV
saying that I don't think that the bill
of rights is like a valid document.
Yes.
That's very radical,
man.
The reason,
by the way,
you're allowed to speak at all right.
I know.
He probably also thinks this is a
fascist country.
I know.
I know that when the Nazis took over at
night in early 1933,
the first thing they did was let
everyone say whatever they want so you
could see,
you could see the mirror images of the
United States and fascist Germany and I
mean it's everywhere.
If you listen to them,
you know,
it was a little kid.
Yeah.
He has a lot of learning to do and I,
I looked back and I look back one day at
that video and go,
oh my God,
I was fucking stupid.
Yeah,
I'm sure he died.
Like,
you look so pompous and proud of
himself.
The state got nobody put a fucking
camera on me when I was 18 and asked me
how the world should work.
Absolutely.
I,
we've all said and done stupid things
and he's too young to realize what's
happening,
but colleges are breeding this sort of
thing and I,
and it's.
I know that people say like it's,
it's overdrawn and it's not as bad as it
is.
And I'm like,
I think it is specifically because when
I was in college,
I only graduated 10 years ago in May.
This wasn't happening and I went to
evergreen state,
Bret Weinstein.
I never saw anything like this in my
life and I,
I never saw.
I never heard about this and other
colleges in Boston,
pretty liberal place.
So this is a newer phenomenon and it's
destructive.
It's core,
it's corrosive,
and it's very damaging to people's
confidence in universities and you know,
like look what's happening to evergreen
state financially that college getting
devastated.
People are voting to defund it and it's
got,
they've,
they have real issues with enrollment
now the,
uh,
the guy that is running,
there was a real interesting article
that I just read yesterday where the
president was talking about what an
impact it's taken on his health and his
mental health and he's unable to think
correctly now and he's unable to like
the guy is like literally shell shocked.
I mean he is.
His decision making skills are very
foggy.
He saying these,
this is what happens when you let
petulant,
ignorant children think that they run up
a,
an establishment of higher learning when
they're there to,
under when you go.
When I entered college,
I went under the knowledge that I didn't
know anything.
How do you turn this around though?
I,
I don't know.
Like I,
I really feel like it,
it comes down in a lot of ways.
It comes down to the people that pay the
bills,
in my opinion.
Feel like the parents need to not be
happy with the product they're getting
when they find that their child is now
an antifa member when he went,
when he,
when he comes back for Thanksgiving or
for Christmas,
you have to ask yourself like,
what is happening?
You know,
like this isn't because
people point back to the sixties when
there was a very righteous wave of anti
authority and anthro
anti-authoritarianism that was born in
this,
in this,
this very specific climate.
You know,
and I think it's going to take a long
time to fix.
I think a lot of it is because of a,
it's a very incestuous.
Academia is very incestuous.
You hire people that agree with you,
you hire people that believe in you.
That's why you find,
what is it like 19 out of 20 people that
teach it at a,
at universities or liberal?
I'm sorry,
like that's insane that that's not
right.
That like even if I,
if I were a liberal or a Democrat,
I'd look at that and be like,
that's not,
that's like it's own form of social
engineering that we,
we've cooperative.
Not only have we call it a lot of media,
which is why the media hates youtube and
they had all these things because they
can't control that,
but now we've co opted academia.
Your ability to get a degree is going to
have to go through these people that
are,
you might be diametrically opposed to or
at the very least aligned to you about a
lot of things and I'm just 10 years ago
that was certainly not my experience.
So I fear for know,
which is another reason why I'm like,
I don't know if college is the best
solution for a lot of even able minded
people,
you know,
like where it's like I don't know what
you get from going there.
Now,
um,
if you,
if you study a discipline,
you'll probably get out.
Okay,
okay.
We're talking about chemistry,
physics,
math,
whatever.
If you're studying humanity,
right?
I don't know,
man.
I don't.
I don't know what you're getting out of
that now.
And I studied the humanity.
I had a lot of liberal professors.
I had a lot of conservative professors.
I wonder what that mix is like now.
And you get different history based on
that.
Yeah.
I get kids send me tweets all the time
of,
uh,
photos of something that their professor
is a showing in class.
Like someone just sent me something the
other day.
It was a photograph of a overhead
projection and it said something about
science being a social construct and
he's like,
this is the kind of shit I'm learning in
school.
Oh,
I think I saw that.
I think I.
Did you retweet it?
You retweeted that?
Yeah,
I saw that pop up on my feet.
Like,
what in the fuck is,
how is this guy a goddamn professor?
Well,
this is the whole thing with like,
you know,
even the,
I mean,
the way this is manifesting itself,
Moses with transgender,
the transgender issue,
which I made a video about this where
I'm like,
I don't know that the science has really
been important.
If a person wants to say that they're a
woman and they were born a man,
I don't really care.
It doesn't matter.
I don't think you need to site typical
justify it.
But I think the scientific justification
for this whole gender normative kind of
thing is actually going to backfire on
them pretty badly because they've
decided to make something that,
you know,
if you get a blood test right and they
can study,
study it,
you're going to come out as a male,
right?
Even if you identify something else,
that doesn't mean you can't identify
like that.
But if you're going to predicate your
whole notion on that,
this is science and it doesn't seem like
that might be the case,
then you're actually injuring the social
movement of people just being accepted
for who they are.
And I feel like this is,
this is where you start engineering
science to,
to fit your narrative.
And I think it's a very,
very dangerous thing.
People,
people do the same thing with global
warming.
I'm a,
I think global warming is obviously
real,
you know,
um,
I think the science says that.
I think that is maybe not as bad,
but it's bad.
It's bad.
It's,
it's effecting things,
making storms worse.
Sea levels are rising.
But people manipulate that to say like,
no,
everything's fine.
Just hand
wave it away,
but it's not true,
you know,
and I feel like,
so I feel like we have to predicate
everything on scientific truth when we
can and then give leeway to say like I
use the example I used was homosexuality
where there was a theory for a long time
that homosexuality wasn't something that
was born in new,
that it was a choice.
Now we know that that's not true,
that it's actually something that's in
you.
But even if it was a choice,
who cares why predicated on that if you
believe in freedom.
Right?
Exactly.
So with the transgender thing,
it's like,
I don't know that you're even attacking
this from the right angle.
You should be attacking it from a social
acceptance angle,
which again goes back to the idea of
like,
I think that's actually the conservative
stance,
you know,
but people would argue with me on that
column.
We're going to do this more often.
Enjoyed this man.
Thank you.
I did too.
Thank you for having me back.
It's a great honor.
Two hours and 20 minutes,
man.
Three hours and 20 minutes,
right?
Three hours and 20 minutes.
Great.
Well I thank you.
Thank you so much.
It was a great honor for you to ask me
back.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations on this space.
Thanks body.
Tell people where they could watch your
show.
Oh,
a youtube.com/
Colin's last stand and I'm often on
twitter at no taxation.
Bam.
See Tomorrow fuckers.
Thanks guys.
Cool.
That was fun.
Thank you.